do you think he is incompetent insane or
evil
the following is a conversation with
coffee Zilla an investigator and
journalist exposing frauds scams and
fake gurus he's one of the most
important journalistic voices we have
working today both in terms of his
integrity and fearlessness in The
Pursuit Of Truth
please follow watch and support his work
at youtube.com
coffeezilla this is the Lex Friedman
podcast to support it please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
dear friends here's coffee Zilla
how do you like your coffee
a dark and soul crushing that was the
number one question on the internet do
you like your coffee to reverberate
deeply through the worst of human nature
is that how you drink your coffee I've
gone through a lot of phases on coffee I
used to in college I would go super deep
into you know grinding fresh beans all
of that kind of stuff water temperature
exactly right and then I hit a phase
where I was just it was the maintenance
dose then I went to like espresso
because I could get a lot more in yeah
and now I go through phases of like
sometimes I like it with a little oat
milk sometimes a little half and half
and sugar oh you've gotten soft in your
old age I've gone a little I I have but
hey if I'm doing a SPF interview it's
black that day nothing less yeah it's
black Notions the lights go down what do
you actually do in that in those
situations like uh leading up to a show
do you get hyped up like how do you put
yourself in the right mind space to
explore some of these really difficult
topics
I think a lot of its preparation and
then once it happens it's mostly fueled
by sort of adrenaline I would say
um
I really deeply care about getting to
like the root cause of some of these
issues because I think so often people
in positions of power let off the hook
so I really care about holding their
feet to the fire and it translates into
like
a lot of energy the day of so I never
find myself like funny enough
I usually drink a lot of caffeine
leading up to the interview and then I
try to drink like minimum the day of
because I have so much adrenaline I
don't want to be like hyper stimulated I
have to say of all the recent guests
I've had the energy you you had when you
walked into the door
was pretty interesting people not
excited
or something you were very excited um
Like That Just Energy it was terrifying
because I'm terrified of social
interaction anyway uh speaking of
terrifying you chose a good living of
interviewing people for face your fears
my friend
uh so let's talk about SPF and FTX who
is uh Sam banquet can you tell a story
from the beginning as you understand it
yeah so Sam Beckman freed is a kid who
grew up sort of from a position of huge
privilege both his parents our lawyers I
believe both of them were from Harvard
he went to MIT went to like or sorry
backing up a bit more he went to like
this top Prep High School then to MIT
then he went to Jane Street and after
that he started a trading firm and I
think 2017 called Alameda research with
a few friends some of them were from
Jane Street some of them worked at
Google and they were sort of the
smartest Kids on the Block or that's
what everyone thought they made a lot of
their money on something called the
kimchi premium or at least this The
Story Goes which just to explain that uh
the price of Bitcoin in Korea was
substantially higher than in the rest of
the world and so you could Arbitrage
that by buying Bitcoin elsewhere and
selling it on a Korean exchange so they
made their money early doing kind of
smart trades like that they flip that
into Market making which they were
pretty early on that
um just providing liquidity to an
exchange and it's what's it's a strategy
that is considered delta neutral which
means basically if you take kind of both
sides of the trade and you're making a
spread like a fee on that you make money
whether it goes up or down so in theory
there shouldn't be that much risk
associated with it so Alameda kind of
blew up because they would offer these
people you know people who are giving
out loans they'd say hey we'll give you
this really attractive rate of return
and we're doing strategies that
seemingly are low risk so we're a low
risk bet where these smart kids from
Jane Street and you can kind of trust us
to be this smarter than everyone else
kind of thing uh around 2019 Sam started
FTX which is an exchange uh specifically
it's specialized in derivatives so like
margins kind of more sophisticated
crypto products
and
it got in with binance early on so
binance actually has a prior
relationship to FTX which we'll explore
in a second because they're going to
play a role in ftx's collapse actually
Finance is the number one uh crypto
exchange and they're led by uh he's
called CZ on Twitter I don't want to
butcher his full name but um really
smart guy has played his hand really
well and built up a quite large exchange
and binance was funding a bunch of
different like startups so they funded
they helped invest into FTX early on
they invested 100 million so these guys
were kind of like teammates early on SBF
and CZ
and FTX quickly grew they got like
especially in 2020 2021 they got a lot
of endorsements they got a lot of
credibility in the space
and eventually FTX actually bought out
binance they gave them two billion
dollars so pretty good investment for
for CZ in a couple years
um and now lead that up to 2022 what
happens Luna collapse three arrows
Capital collapse which if you don't know
there's just these kind of cataclysmic
events in crypto uh led by some pretty
risky Behavior whether Luna was a token
that promised really attractive returns
that were unsustainable ultimately and
it just kind of spiraled it did what's
called a stable coin death spiral which
we can talk about if we need to the
stable cool and death spiral I can't
wait till that like actually enters the
Lexicon like a Wikipedia page on it like
uh economic students are learning it at
school yes it's like a chapter in a book
anyway
um I mean this is the reality of our
world this is a really big part of our
of the economic system is cryptocurrency
and stablecoin is part of that yeah it's
weird because on the one hand
cryptocurrency is supposed to somewhat
simplify or add transparency to the
financial markets the idea is for the
first time you don't have to wait for an
SEC filing from some corporate business
you can look at what they're doing on
chain right
um so that's good because a lot of big
financial problems are caused by lack of
transparency and lack of understanding
risk but ironically you get some people
creating these arbitrarily complicated
Financial products like algorithmic
stable coins which then introduce more
risk and blow everything up so anyways
uh three hours Capital blew up
and all of a sudden this crypto industry
which everyone thought was going to the
Moon Bitcoin to a hundred thousand is in
some trouble and FTX seems like the only
people who besides like binance who's
also really big and stable and coinbase
they seemed like they were doing fine in
fact they were bailing out companies in
the summer I don't know if you remember
that SBF was likened to like Jamie
Diamond who's the you know CEO of Chase
who like kind of was like the buck stops
here uh you know
I'm like the backstop right so SPF was
supporting the industry he was like the
stable guy so come to like around
October and November there's all this
talk about regulation everything's been
blowing up sbfs leading the charge on
regulation and CZ the CEO of Finance
gets word that maybe SBF is kind of like
cutting them out or making regulation
that would maybe impact his business
and uh he doesn't like that too much
they start kind of feuding a little bit
on Twitter so when it comes out a
coindesk report came out that
ftx's balance sheet wasn't looking that
good like it looked pretty weak they had
a lot of coins that in theory had value
if you looked at their market price but
for a variety of reasons if you tried to
sell them they'd collapse in value so
it's sort of like this thing a house
built on Sand and uh a friend of mine on
Twitter he goes by Dirty Bubble media he
released a report and he basically said
I think these uh these guys are
insolvent well CZ saw that and he
retweeted it and started adding fuel to
the fire of like the speculation because
up till this point everyone thought FTX
is super safe super secure there's no
reason to not keep your money there Tom
Brady keeps his money there whatever
and CZ kind of feel adds fuel to the
fire by saying not only am I retweeting
this adding kind of like validity to
this speculation but also I'm going to
take the ftt that I got which part of
their balance sheet was this ftt token
which is ftx's like proprietary token
and Alameda and FTX control a lot of it
they were using this token to basically
be a large amount of collateral for
their whole balance sheet so it
accounted for this huge amount of their
value and the CEO of binance had a huge
chunk of it as well and he said I'm
going to sell all of it
and the I the fuel that that introduced
to the market is if he sells all this
ftt and this ftt is underwriting a lot
of the value of FTX does fdt's almost
approximate like uh similar things if
you were to buy a stock in a public
company is that kind of like a stock in
FTX it sort of was this proxy because
what FTX was committed to doing was sort
of like buying back ftt tokens they
would do this thing called the buy and
burn I think there was some amount of
sharing in the revenue fees of FTX it
was kind of this convoluted thing in my
opinion the exact value of ftt was
speculative from the beginning and it
was clear that it was very tied to the
performance of FTX which is important
because we'll get to later FTX sort of
built their whole scaffold on ftt which
meant that this scaffold was very wobbly
because if FTX loses a little bit of
confidence then your value goes down
when your value goes down you lose more
confidence and this goes down so it was
kind of like this thing that this
flywheel that when it was going well you
got huge amounts of growth when it's
going bad you get a uh exchange death
spiral so to speak actually this
structure it's a pretty non-standard
structure did The Architects of its
initial design
anticipate the wobbliness of the whole
system so putting fraud and all those
things that happen later aside do you
think it was difficult to anticipate
this kind of FDT FTX elemented research
weird dynamic no because I think
sophisticated Traders always think in
terms of diversification and correlation
so if you're trying to the way to think
about risk in investing is like if I
invest in
you Lex Friedman and then I also invest
in some product you produce those those
the performance of those two things will
be pretty correlated so whether I invest
in you or I invest in this product that
you like are completely behind
I'm not de-risking I'm basically
counting all on you doing well right and
if you do bad my investments do very bad
so if I'm trying to build a stable thing
I shouldn't put all my eggs in The Lex
Friedman basket unless I'm positive that
you're going to do well right and these
people as your financial advisor I would
definitely recommend you do not put all
your eggs in this basket right and so
you can think about it like if I know
that these people were trained to think
like this and so the idea that you could
start this exchange you're worth
billions of dollars and you underwrite
your whole system by betting putting
most of it on your own token is is
insane and what and what's crazy is
we'll later find out that they were
basically taking customer assets which
were real things like Bitcoin and
ethereum with with risks that were not
so correlated to FDX and they were
swapping them out they were using to go
go basically gamble those and putting
ftt in its place as quote value so they
were increasing the risk of the system
in order to bet big with the idea that
if they bet big in one we'd all be
singing their praises if we bet big and
law if they bet big and lost
I don't know if they had a plan but I
think they were I think they were being
extremely risky and there's no way to
avoid their knowledge of That So when
you say customer assets is I come to
this crypto exchange I have Bitcoin or
some other cryptocurrency and this is a
a thing that has
pretty stable value over time I mean
yeah right that's crypto relative
relatively so and I'm going to store it
on this crypto exchange and that that's
the whole point this is uh
so this thing to the degree that crypto
holds value
is supposed to continue holding value
there's not there's not supposed to be
an extra risk inserted into the thing
right and FTX was pretty clear from the
beginning that they wouldn't invest your
assets in anything else they wouldn't do
anything else with it they wouldn't
trade it
that's what made FTX so such like a
horror story for investor confidence is
basically they made every signal that
they would not do anything nefarious
with your tokens they would just put
them to the side put them in a separate
account that they don't have access to
and they just kind of wait there until
the day that you're ready to withdraw
them that's explicitly what they told
their customers so going back to the
story a little bit CZ then says hey I'm
selling this token that underwrites the
value of FTX there's a total panic
SPF during this time makes set says
several lies such as FTX assets are fine
we have enough money to cover all
withdrawals
um and a day later he basically admits
that that wasn't the case they don't
have the money they're shutting down and
then a few days later after that they
declared bankruptcy
there's I should be clear there's
Alameda research FTX International and
FTX us which is the U.S side of things
these are three different entities
all of them are on bankruptcy and it's
not clear to the extent that they were
co-mingling funds but it's clear that
they were co-mingling funds to some
extent so they kind of worked taking
from each other and that is where the
fraud happens right because if going
back to our earlier analogy if you're
supposed to set funds aside and I find
out you were using it to go make all
these Arbitrage trades or do Market
making or all these activities you were
known for for your like hedge fund
trading firm thing that's a huge problem
because you he basically lied about this
and especially when he's saying
explicitly that we have these things we
have these funds and these things turn
out to be lies well again the question
of fraud comes in and it's just like
there's no way he didn't know so the
obvious question might be well why isn't
he locked up why why is he running
around and it's because
um
really his story is that he didn't know
any of it he found out that they had to
steal mana's position he would say he
was totally disconnected from what
Alameda was doing he had no idea that
they had such a large margin position
that they had an accounting Quirk and
that accounting Quirk hit eight billion
dollars from um from
his View and so when he was saying that
they had money to cover it he was saying
that truthfully to the best of his
ability and he just was so distracted at
the time that he made a series of
increasingly embarrassing mistakes and
now he owes it to the people to write
those wrongs by publicly making this
huge apology tour so you might have seen
him on I mean he's been talking to
nearly everyone
um
about basically how he's just didn't
know what he's doing he's the stupidest
man alive uh so what what what are some
interesting things you've learned from
those interviews
I think I've appreciated why you don't
talk in that position uh most people
wouldn't talk most people would listen
to their legal counsel and and not talk
I do not think he's any lawyer worth
their salt would tell him to talk
because right now I think the danger of
what he's doing is he's locking himself
into a story of how things happened and
I don't think that story is going to
hold up in the coming months because I
think it's impossible from The Insider
conversations I've had with Alameda
research employees with FTX employees
it's impossible to square what they are
telling me with no like incentive to lie
with what SBF is telling me with every
incentive to lie which is fundamentally
that he didn't know they were
co-mingling funds he didn't know they
were gambling with customer money and it
was basically this huge mistake and it's
alameda's fault but he wasn't involved
in Alameda a company he owned so like uh
compassionate but heart hitting gangster
that you are recently very recently you
interact with SPF on dialect I I just uh
the suspenders as you're saying this
you interact on Twitter spaces uh with
SPF
and uh really put his feet to the fire
uh with some hard-hitting questions what
did you ask and what did you learn from
that interaction
sure I should say first this was not a
willing interaction I mean I thought
that was kind of the funny part of it
because I've been asking him for an
interview for a while he's been giving
interviews to nearly everyone who wants
one big channels small channels
um he didn't give me one but I managed
to get some by sneaking up on some
Twitter spaces and dming the people and
like being like hey can I come up so I
didn't get him to ask everything that I
wanted because he like would leave
sometimes uh you know after I asked some
of the questions but really what I asked
was about this 8 billion and zooming in
on the improbability of his lack of
knowledge
um it's sort of like if you if you run a
company and you know the insides and
outs and you're the top of your field
top top in class
and all of a sudden it all goes busting
you say I had no idea how any of this
worked yeah I didn't I didn't know it's
like the guy who runs Whataburger saying
I didn't know where we sourced our beef
I didn't know where we that's a Texas
example actually thank you I appreciate
it uh let's let's take it like worldwide
Walmart like I didn't know we used
Chinese manufacturers it's like that's
impossible to become Walmart you have to
know how like how your supply chain
works you have to know even if you're at
a high level you know how this stuff
works can I do a hard turn on that and
go sure as one must to Hitler uh
Hitler's writing is not on any of the
documents around as far as I know uh on
the final solution so in in some crazy
world you could theoretically say I knew
I didn't know anything about death camps
uh so there's this plausible deniability
in theory so that's but that most people
would look at that and say uh it's very
unlikely you don't know especially if
all the Insiders are coming out and
saying no no of course he knew he was
directing us from the top I mean um what
was clear what's interesting about the
structure and like I love the knitting
yeah we're back to SPF yeah sorry now
we're back I wanted to turn us as fast
as possible
um I yeah I so the Insiders in what
Almer Alameda research what was
interesting is that there was this sort
of one-way window going on between
Alameda and FTX where FTX employees
didn't know a lot of what was going on
Alameda insiders and I would say by
Design knew almost everything that was
going on at FTX
um and so I think that was really
interesting from the perspective of a
lot of the so-called like what you could
which he's trying to ascribe to as like
failures or mistakes or ignorance and
negligence when looked at closely are
much more designed and they sort of
don't arise spontaneously because like
let's say so there's this thing in
banking and like trading where if I run
a bank and you run like a trading firm
we need to have informational walls
between us because there's huge
conflicts of interest that can arise
right so the negligent argument might be
that like oh we just didn't know we're
sort of these dumb kids in the Bahamas
so we shared information equally
but when you see a one-way wall that
starts to look a lot different right if
I have a back-end source of looking at
or sorry you're the trading firm so you
have a back-end way to look at all my
accounts and I have no idea that you're
doing that that all of a sudden looks
like a much more designed thing when it
would be plausible let's say going to to
use another another analogy too if
you're saying look I co-mingled funds
because I was so bad at corporate
structures you would expect those
companies to have a very simple
corporate structure because you didn't
know what you're doing right but what we
see with FTX and Alameda
is they had something like 50 companies
and subsidiaries and it's Inc impossibly
complicated web of corporate activity
you don't get there by accident you
don't wake up and go oh I designed like
this watch that ticked a very specific
way but it was all accidental if you
really didn't know what you were doing
you'd end up with a simple structure so
even just like from a fundamental
perspective what SPF was doing and like
the activities they were engaging in
were so complicated and purposely
designed to obfuscate what they were
doing it's impossible to subscribe to
the negligence argument and I want to
quickly say too like I don't think a lot
of people have honed in on this there
was insider trading going on
From alameda's perspective where
they would know what coins FTX was going
to list on their exchange there's a
famous effect where let's say you're
this legitimate exchange you list a coin
the price spikes
insiders told me it was a regular
practice for Alameda insiders to know
that FTX was going to list a coin and as
a company buy up that coin so they could
sell it after it listed and they made
millions of dollars how do you do that
accidentally yeah and that's that's
illegal totally illegal so that's
illegal from like and if an individual
does it it's illegal it's fraud what if
a company is systematically doing it and
you can't tell me that FTX
or someone at FTX wasn't feeding that
information about to Alameda or somehow
giving them keys to know that and that
would happen at the highest level it
would happen at SPS level and this is
why his arguments of I was dumb I was
naive I was sort of ignorant or so
Preposterous because he's dumb and
ignorant the second it becomes criminal
to be smart and sophisticated right
but then also coming out and talking
about it which is uh
it's a bizarre move it's a bizarre and
almost a dark move uh can you tell the
story of the 8 billion you mentioned 8
billion what's the 8 billion what's the
missing eight billion yeah so it's
really interesting because it's sort of
like wire fraud you sort of he's sort of
copping to like smaller crimes to avoid
the big crime the big crime is you knew
everything and you were behind it right
the smaller crimes are like a little
wire fraud here little wire fraud there
so what the 8 billion is is that FTX
didn't always have banking it's hard to
get banking as a crypto exchange there's
all these questions of like where's the
money coming from is it coming from
money launder so
for a variety of reasons it's always
been hard for exchanges to get bank
accounts so before when FTX was just
getting started they didn't have a bank
account so how do you put money on FTX
well they would have you wire your money
to their trading firm their wiring
instructions would go to their trading
firm it's easier to get banking as a
trading firm so you'd put your money
with the trading firm and then they'd
credit you the money on FTX
okay first of all this is a whole
circumvention of all these banking
guidelines and regulations
that's the first like thing that I think
is legal but
basically what SBF argued is that there
was an accounting glitch error problem
where when you'd send money to Alameda
even though they'd credit you on FTX
they wouldn't Safeguard your deposits
like your deposits would go into what he
called a stub account which is just like
some
account that's not very well labeled
kind of like a placeholder account
and
he didn't realize that those were
alameda's funds or they were playing
with those funds and that they basically
should have safeguarded that for
customers that's his explanation it's
Preposterous because it's eight billion
dollars but anyways
um just poor labeling of accounts of an
8 billion dollar account I mean it's
like a billion a billion this is like
doing this all the time this is the
craziest thing like he was he was
talking to me and at one point in the
conversation he's like yeah I didn't
have precise not because he said I
didn't have knowledge of alameda's
accounts and I said well Forbes a month
ago was getting detailed accounting of
Alameda and he goes oh that wasn't
detailed accounting I just knew I was
right within 10 billion or so
what is that error margin 10 billion
dollars for a company that is arguably
never worth more than 100 million yeah
that probably never never even worth
more than 50 billion your error margin
is 10 billion you have to be this is a
guy who is sending around
statements that like there was no risk
involved and you're telling me he had a
error margin of 10 billion dollars that
is the difference between like a healthy
company and a company so deep underwater
you're going to jail
so it you have to believe that he is
impossibly stupid and square that with
the sophistication that he brought to
the table it's an I think it's an
impossible argument I I don't even think
it's do you think he is incompetent
insane or evil
if you were to bet
money on each of those incompetent
insane or evil insane meaning he's lying
to everyone but also to himself
uh which you could which is a little bit
different than incompetence he's not
incompetent
so the I think he's some combination of
insane and evil but it's impossible to
know unless we know deep inside his
heart how self
like deluded he is versus a calculated
strategy and I think if you look at SBF
he's such a I think he's a fascinating
individual just I mean you know he's a
horrible human being let's start there
but he's also somewhat
um
interesting from a psychology
perspective because he's very open about
the fact that he understands image and
he understands how to cultivate image
the importance of image so well that I
think a lot of people even though
they've talked about it aren't
emphasizing that enough
when interacting with him this is a man
whose entire history is about
cultivating the right opinions at the
right time to achieve the right effect
why do you think he would suddenly
change that approach when he has all the
more reason to cultivate an image so he
is extremely good naturally or uh I
don't know if he's good but he's like
he's a hyper aware so he's deliberate in
cultivating a Public Image and
controlling the Public Image you you
know about the like Democrat donations
like he he knew to donate to the right
people 40 million dollars he says on a
call that we released with Tiffany Fong
he says on a call that he donated the
same amount to Republicans there's
speculation on whether this is true
because he's a liar whatever so caveat
there but he said he donated to
Republicans the same amount but he
donated dark because he knew that most
journalists are liberal and they would
kind of hold that against him so he
wanted all the all the sides to be on in
his favor in his pocket while
simultaneously understanding the entire
media landscape and playing them like a
fiddle by cultivating this image of I'm
this Progressive woke billionaire who
wants to give it all away do everything
for charity I drive a Corolla while
living in a million dollar Penthouse
multi-million
um but but that was sort of the angle he
he understood so well how to play the
media and um
I do I think he underestimated when he
did this how much people would put him
under a deeper microscope and I don't
think he has achieved the same level of
success in cultivating this new image
because I think people are so skeptical
now no one's buying it but I think he
he's trying it he's doing it to the best
but it has work leading up to this
particular wobbly situation so before
that was in their public perception of
him being
a Force for good a financial 100 yeah
somebody from Sequoia Capital you know
wrote this glowing review that he's
going to be the world's first
trillionaire there's so many pieces done
on he's the most generous billionaire in
the world that um he was sort of like
the
Steel Man of you know it's possible to
make tons of money this is like the
effect of altruism movement make as much
money as you can as fast as you can and
give it all away and he was sort of like
the the poster child for that and he did
give some of it away and got a lot of
press for it and I think that was kind
of by Design I want to address a real
quick Point yes a lot of people have
said that like binance played a role and
while they catalyzed this
insolvency
is a problem that will eventually
manifest either way so I don't put any
blame on CZ for basically causing this
meltdown the the underlying Foundation
was unstable and it was going to fall
apart at the next push I mean he just
happened to be the final kind of like
uh I don't know the straw that broke the
camel's back yeah the Catalyst are
revealed yeah but it's like I don't
culpable for ftx's like malfeasance and
how they handle accounts if that makes
sense so what what role did they play
could they have helped alleviate some of
the pain of um
uh investors of people that held funds
there yeah I mean
probably uh I don't know I I would see
some kind of weird obligation like with
the 2 billion they made on FTX remember
they got 2 billion some of it in cash
some of it in some of it in FDT token so
I don't know how much actual cash they
have from that deal but they have
billions from the success of what seems
to be a fraud seems to have been a fraud
from early on they had the back door as
early as 20 early 2020 from what I can
tell so the the back door between FTX
and now I mean Alameda research do you
think CZ saw through who SPF is
what is he's doing
no I think
I think CZ is like he's a shark I think
he's he's good at building a big
business
um like a good I don't go back truck I
don't know I don't know I think sharks
just eat I mean I I don't I don't know I
think uh my relationship with Shaw has
like Finding Nemo there's a shark in
that sure I don't know I think like Jeff
Bezos is a shark okay so whether you
people have loaded connotations of like
how they feel about Jeff Bezos I mean I
I would say like I think CZ is a
ruthless businessman
I think it's qualities calculated he's
very
um deliberate and
I think uh what he should do in this
position is forfeit the funds that he
profited from that investment because
largely I think it was
um it's owed to the customers there's so
much hurting out there so I think I
think they could do a lot of good around
that
um I don't know if they will because I
don't know if he sees it in his best
interest I think that's probably how
he's thinking but yeah I I think they
could have helped or they could still
help there who do you think suffered the
most from this so far
the little account holders this is
always true so one of the big
Temptations with fraud I've covered a
lot of scams frauds is everyone looks at
the big number everyone that's the
headline billions of dollars the top 50
creditors or whatever one thinks of
first
uh but quickly when you dig down you
realize that most people who lost 10
million dollars I mean I'm sure that's
terrible for them I wish them to get
their money back but uh it's usually the
people with like 50 000 or less that are
most impacted usually they do not have
the money to spare usually they're not
Diversified in a sophisticated way
um so I think it's those people I think
it's the small account holders that I
feel the worst for and unfortunately
they often get the least press time or
air time that's a really difficult truth
of this is that especially in the
culture of cryptocurrency there's a lot
of young people who are not Diversified
they're basically all in on a particular
crypto
and it just breaks my heart to think
that there's somebody fifty thousand or
thirty thousand or Twenty Thousand but
the point is that money
is everything they own
right and now
now what their life is basically
destroyed
like you know imagine your 18 19 20 21
years old
you saved up you've been working you
saved up
and this is this is it this is basically
destroying a life
what's so brutal about this is that this
all comes on the back the entire crypto
Market comes on the back of
comes from the deep distrust of
traditional Finance right yeah 2008
everybody lost trust in the banking
systems and they lost trust that if
those banking systems acted in a corrupt
way that they would receive the Justice
it turned out that the banks received
favorable treatment people didn't so
people
lost faith in the the structure of our
financial system in a way that is we're
still feeling the reverberations of it
and so when crypto came along it was
like kind of this way to reinvent the
wheel reinvent the world for the the
like sort of lowly and the like less
powerful and kind of level the playing
field so it's so sad about events like
this is you see that fundamentally a lot
of the the power structures are the same
where the people at the top uh face
little repercussions for what they do
the people at the bottom are still
getting screwed the people at the bottom
are still getting lied to and law
enforcement is way behind the ball
do you think this really uh
damage people trust in cryptocurrency
for sure way bigger than uh Luna way
bigger than three hours Capital it's
because of who SBF was it's not just the
dollar figure behind it it's because he
wooed so many of our media Elites who
should have been calling him out or at
least investigating him and not rubber
stamping him
it's an indictment of our financial
system or even our most sophisticated
people in Blackrock in Sequoia who
didn't see this coming who also rubber
stamped him
um
and you just wonder like if you can't
trust the top people in crypto who are
supposedly the good guys the guys saving
crypto I month just a month ago or two
months ago he was the guy on Capitol
Hill that was talking to Gary Gensler to
all the top people in Washington he was
orchestrating the regulation of crypto
if that guy is a complete fraudster liar
psychopath and nobody knew it until it
was too late what does that mean about
the system itself that we're building so
you are one of not the best
like fraudster
investigators in the world did you sense
did you uh was this on your radar at all
SPF in the over the past couple years
were any red flags going off for you yes
so funny enough like one of my videos
from six months ago or so blew up
because um
I got to give a lot of credit to Matt
Levine of Bloomberg great journalist
great Finance journalist and I want to
say when I like talk about media Elite
there are people doing great work in
these mainstream institutions it's not a
monolith just like Independent Media
isn't all doing great work and all the
corporate media is bad or whatever
there's like these overarching
narratives that I don't subscribe to so
Matt Levine's great journalist he he
didn't interview with SPF where
he got Sam to basically describe a lot
of what was going on in D5 but at kind
of a larger philosophy around crypto and
he described a Ponzi scheme where he
just described this black box it does
nothing but if we ascribe it value then
we can create more value and more value
and more value and it kind of was this
ridiculous description of a Ponzi scheme
but there was no moral judgment on it it
was like oh yeah this is great we can
make a lot of money from this and Matt
is like well it sounds like you're in
the Ponzi business and business is good
I made a video about that I said this is
ridiculous this is absurd whatever it's
obscene
but
um
I didn't explicitly call SBF a fraud
there
and I think if if I'm being I think I
saw some of it but like many people I
think a lot of us were kind of like
I think a lot of us missed how wrong
everyone could be at the same time
I did notice leading up to the crash
what was happening and I and I caught it
out a day a day or a day and a half
before it happened because I saw my
friends post a dirty bubble media and
this was the first real look into the
heart of their finances because they're
this black box you just kind of had to
evaluate them
without knowing much
and once we got a peek under the hood of
what their finances were
I realized oh my gosh these guys might
be completely insolvent so I made a
tweet about it I hope some people saw it
and got their money out
um
but pretty quickly after that I caught
The Narrative of what was really going
on at Alameda
that it was basically this Ponzi scheme
that they had built do you ever sit like
Batman in The Dark since he fight crime
and wonder like sad just staring into
the darkness and thinking I should have
caught this earlier
yeah I think in your in your uh 10
billion dollars 10 million dollars 10
million dollars we're working our way
there
um sure like it's never enough It's
never enough like you always could be
catching stuff sooner you always could
be doing more I mean the fascinating
thing you said is that
one of the lessons here is that a large
number of people influential smart
people could all be wrong at the same
time in terms of their evaluation of SBF
this is this is one thing that I don't
understand too is like I think it's one
thing to not see something
I think it's another thing to like
rubber stamp or explicitly endorse I
feel like
a lot of people didn't look too close at
SPF because I think a lot of the warning
signs were there but my feeling is if
you're a sequoia if you're a black rock
wouldn't you do that due diligence I
mean like yeah like before just
endorsing something especially in the
crypto space this is just why I don't do
any deals in the crypto space ever
because it's impossible to know which
ones are going to be the like big hits
or the big frauds or you know whatever
um but if you're going to make that bet
if you're going to make that play you
would think
that you would do all the research in
the world and you would get
sophisticated looks at their liabilities
at how they were structured all that
stuff and that is the most shocking part
is not that you know people missed it
because you can miss fraud but that
there were so much so many glowing
endorsements like this guy is not going
to be that thing we explicitly endorse
him I saw a Fortune Magazine he was
called the next Warren Buffett it's just
crazy do you think it's possible to have
enough like Tom Brady
uh endorsements that you don't really
investigate so like yes there's a kind
of momentum like societal social
momentum I think that's the problem I
actually think that's hugely a blind
like a a blind spot of our society as we
have all these heuristics that can be
points of failure where like a rule of
thumb is if you go to an Ivy League well
you must be smart right a rule of thumb
is if you're both your parents are
Harvard lawyers you must not you must
know the law you must like kind of be
sophisticated the rule of thumb is if
you're running a billion dollar exchange
you must be somehow somewhat ethical
right and all of these heuristics can
lead to Giant blind spots where you kind
of just go oh we'll check like I don't
really it's a lot of energy to look into
people and if enough of those rules of
thumb are met we just kind of check them
off and put them through the system so
uh yeah it's been hugely exposing for
sort of like and you don't know maybe
how to look at for example there's a few
assumptions now there's a lot of people
are very skeptical of institutions of
government and so on but for um perhaps
too much so I agree but for some part of
history there was a too much faith in
government yeah and so uh right now I
think there's faith in certain large
companies there's distrust in certain
ones and Trust in others like people
seem to distrust Facebook extremely
skeptical Facebook but they trust I
think Google with their data I think
they trust apple with their data sure
much much more so like search people
don't seem to be a Google search like
I'm just gonna I'm gonna throw it in
there have you ever looked at your
Google search history your Google search
history has got to be the some of the
darkest things oh I don't think I've
ever looked at my Google search history
you should be careful with uh like
browser hygiene and uh stuff like that
because I think it's
well Google search history unless you
explicitly delete is there I recommend
you look at it it's fascinating look
because it goes back to the first days
of you using Google search history fun
fact actually about that no no I I I am
I am aware of that
um I just mean for like certain
sensitive topics where like I'm
investigating some fraud and I go sign
into their website right log in I won't
use like a traditional browser I'll use
a VPN and I'll like put it on like Brave
or something like that you log in you
create an account as Lex Friedman yeah
exactly exactly exactly uh you mentioned
effective altruism yes you know SPF has
been associated with this effective
altruism which made me look twice at EA
sure and see like wait
um
ID what's what's going on here
uh is this was this used by SBF to give
himself a good Public Image or is there
something about effective altruism that
makes it easy to misuse by bad people
what do you think yeah it's interesting
he could have endorsed a wide range of
philosophies and I guess you just have
to wonder
are all those would those philosophies
also be tainted if
um he had gone bad I guess effective
altruism is sort of unique because he
used it as part of his brand it wasn't
like he was he described himself as a
consequentialist and like that ended up
mattering it was like he described
himself as an effective altruist and he
used that part of the brand to lift
himself up I guess that's why it's
getting so much scrutiny
um I think the merits of it should speak
for themselves I mean I don't personally
I'm not personally an effective altruist
um I personally am motivated by giving
in part emotionally and for some reason
that I can't exactly describe I think
that's somewhat important I don't think
you should detach giving from some
personal connection I I find trouble
with that
and and like I said it's for reasons I
Can't Describe because effective
altruism is sort of the most logical
Ivory Tower position you could possibly
take it's like strip all Humanity away
from giving let's treat it like a
business and how many people can we
serve through the McDonald's line of
charity for like the dollar right
um I just personally don't resonate with
that but I don't think the entire
movement is like
indicted because of it typically most
people who care about giving and charity
on the whole are nice people and are so
I can't speak for the whole movement I
certainly don't think SBF indicts the
whole movement even though I personally
don't subscribe to it yeah that it made
me pause reflect and step back like um
about the movement and about anything
that has a strong ideology so if there's
anything in your life that's a strong
set of ideas behind it be careful yeah I
mean look I kind of feel like what it
teaches me and what I kind of think
about when I think about systems is that
no system saves you from the individual
no system saves you from the individual
their intentions their their lust for
power or greed I mean I think one of the
great ideas
is the decentralization of power and
like this is why
I think democracies are so great is
because they decentralize power across a
wide range of like interests and groups
and that being an effective way to kind
of try as best as you can to spread out
the impact of one individual because one
bad individual can do a lot of harm as I
mean clearly as seen here but um no I
don't think it has anything to do with
ideology because it's not like being an
effective altruist made Sam bankman free
to fraud he was a fraud who happened to
be an effective Walter well this makes
sense so there is something about yes no
system protects you from an individual
but some system
enable or service a better Catalyst than
others for uh for the worst aspects of
human nature so for example communist
ideology I don't know if it's the
ideology or its implementation in this
in the in the 20th century it seemed
like such a sexy and powerful and viral
ideology that it somehow allows the evil
bad people to like sneak into the very
top and so like that's what I mean about
certain ideas sound so nice
that allow you like the the lower
classes the workers the people that do
all the work they should have power they
they have been screwed over for far too
long they need to take power back that
sounds like a really powerful idea and
then it just seems like with those
powerful ideas
evil people sneak in to the top and
start to abuse that power yeah I think
I mean I don't have a lot of probably
big brain political takes but what I can
say is that you can never get away from
both the system and the individual
mattering for sure some systems
incentivize some behaviors in certain
ways but some people will take that and
go okay all we need to do is design the
perfect system and then these
individuals will act completely
rationally or responsibly in accordance
to what our incentives say that's not
true you could also say all we have to
do is focus on the individual and all we
have to do is just create a society
which raises very well-adjusted people
and then we can throw them into any
system with any incentives and they will
act like responsibly ethically morally
and I also don't think that's true so
incentives are real but also
the individual ultimately plays a large
role too so yeah I don't know I come
down sort of in the middle there and
some of that is just accidents of
History to which individuals finds which
system you know uh become the face of
that yeah with FTX versus uh coinbase
versus binance which individual would
which kinds of ideas and uh life story
come to power because that matters it's
kind of fascinating that history turns
on these small little events done by
small little individuals that uh you
know Hitler's a failed artist or you
have FDR or you have uh all these
different characters that do good or do
evil into the world and it's like single
individuals and they have a life story
and it could have turned out completely
different it's I mean it's the flap of
the butterfly wings so yeah you're right
it we should be skepticals attributing
too much to the system or the individual
it's all like a Beautiful Mess
that's like that was like a Lex line
I've heard I've heard quite a few
episodes and that's like such a Lex line
it's a beautiful map all right
beautifully said all right sorry I'm a
fan of the show okay all right I love
you too uh all right
can you think of possible trajectories
how this
FTX SPF Saga ends uh and which one do
you hope for do you hope that SBF goes
to jail
and that's the individual and in terms
of the investors and the customers what
do you hope happens and what do you
think are the possible things that can
happen
so hey yeah I definitely think SPF
should go to jail
um for nothing else for a semblance of
Justice the facsimile of Justice to
occur for all the investors
um I also think there are people
probably several steps down the chain
that probably knew at least Caroline
Ellison you can have questions about
sort of their you know Dan Friedberg who
I'd love to talk about as well
um there are a lot of people in that
room who I think knew I think we do so
much of like the one guy is All To Blame
let's throw everything at him when
clearly this was a
company-wide issue so everyone who knew
I think should face
the same punishment which I think should
be jail for all of those people
um
in part to send a signal to anybody that
tries this kind of stuff in the future
yeah absolutely I mean one of the big
things that you saw like okay take a
microcosm of all of this action and just
look at like the influencer space right
there's a ton of deals that were done
that I've covered Ad nauseam about
influencer finds out they can make a lot
of money selling a crypto coin the first
thing they wonder is am I going to get
caught
if I do this is there a consequence and
if the answer is no then it's a pretty
easy decision as long as you don't like
have any moral scriptures about it which
apparently none of them did or a lot of
them did and I should say
so
as soon as somebody steps in and
regulates that math changes and all of a
sudden there's a self-interest reason to
not go do the bad thing so for example
and I can give a concrete example of
this
there was a nft the first ever nft sort
of like
official indictment or the doj released
this press release that they're charging
these guys who ran a nft project that
they didn't follow through on their
promises they made all these promises
lied and then ran away with the money
first ever consequence for anyone in the
nft space that day that that press
release came out I saw several nft
um projects come back to life from the
dead
why because all those Founders are
freaking out and they realized we
scammed people we have to go at least
make make it look like we're doing the
right thing right even just so that's on
the optic side but there's also tons of
people who now go oh the basically law
enforcement is on the scene we can't do
the same thing so there is a very
pragmatic reason to for this punishment
it's very much just because people work
it into their math of should I commit
fraud and the last several years have
been very
um sort of has been like a little bit of
a nihilistic landscape where no one was
getting punished and so there's this
question of you're almost an idiot if
you didn't take the deals
um so I think it's really important
extremely important for kind of law
enforcement to play a role regulation to
play a role to make it harder to commit
those crimes and if you commit those
crimes there's actual real world
punishment for it
to your point about like what's going to
happen to the investors I think that was
kind of your question
it's tough because the if the money's
not there the money's not there I mean
there's going to be the guy they got the
Best in Class guy it's the guy who ran
the dissolving of Enron so I mean I
can't imagine someone better equipped to
run a complicated corporate fraud like
dissolution but
yeah it's it's tough because everyone's
going to get probably I don't know 10
cents on the dollar maybe less I wonder
if there's a way to do a progressive
redistribution of funds so I just I'm
just really worried about the pain that
small investors feel I think yeah I
think um there's a lot of thought around
that I forget if
if they actually do do this I mean I
know there's a lot of law about like you
can't treat
creditors differently you have to treat
them all the same so I think it'll be
some kind of proportional payback it's
certainly not going to be that the guys
at the top get you know a significant
amount of their money back and the rest
get nothing unfortunately I think
there's such a
small amount of assets that back this
whole thing in the end and that value is
actually declining every day because it
was inextricably tied to FBF it was like
the ftt tokens which now what are those
worth the serum tokens that was his
project or the project they made what is
that worth basically nothing so you know
it's a very it's a hard situation and
you know there's a bigger ethical
concern which is FTX us
it's unclear how backed it was but it
was clearly more backed than FTX
International
do you take all that money and throw it
into a big pot and give people money
back or do you give the US people back
their amount of money which is probably
going to be significantly more and leave
everyone internationally out in the cold
and to add to that ethical issue let's
say you're a liquidator and you're
us-based there's a tremendous question
like legal questions about you know how
do you ethically do that it's not it's
not clear there's a tremendous incentive
to just favor the U.S people over
everyone else because it's our country
America whatever but um I don't know if
that's necessarily Fair it's it's really
hard it's like it's impossible and some
uh I forget where you said this but one
of the I mean it probably uh permeates a
lot of the investigations you do which
is this idea that it's really sad that
the middle class in most situations like
this get [ __ ] over so the the IRS I'll
go after the middle class they'll go
after the rich is basically everyone who
doesn't have a lot of Leverage in terms
of lawyers money get [ __ ] over
yes and then they're the ones like it's
always the rich and Powerful who get the
favorable treatment as it like a
microcosm of this funny story so
one of the big criticisms of crypto and
I think rightly so is the
irreversibility of the transaction so if
I accidentally send a transaction
somewhere it's gone right yeah so
crypto.com accidentally sent a lady 10
million dollars
and now they want the money back and
they're suing her but the funny thing is
is if you are on crypto.com and you send
let's say I accidentally send you money
and I come knocking on your door it
looks I didn't mean to send you you know
like uh a thousand dollars I need my
money back
or if I go to crypto.com and I said hey
I sent that to the wrong person can you
reverse it they'll say screw off no way
if I go to court they'll kill me in
court because they're going to go look
this is how the blockchain works but
then they do it they do the exact same
thing they send this lady 10 million
dollars they're suing or no they're
going to win now it's now what's in
court is not whether they get the money
back it's should she be liable for theft
I believe so
and that's in just another case of
the same rules apply differently to
different people whether you have the
money to back you or not it's a very sad
thing and that's why I think people like
you need
journalists fighting for
the little person
we really need it and it's kind of like
this unfortunate thing where that's the
most risky thing to do like legally you
should not be doing that but
um I think it's important to do it's the
ethical thing it's the right thing to do
uh what do you think about influencers
and celebrities that supported FTX and
SBF do they should they be punished yeah
I think I think they should take a huge
reputational hit I mean I think they
should be embarrassed I think they
should be ashamed of themselves but it
was really hard to know sorry to
interrupt for them to know like for
example I think about this a lot yeah
it's like
who do I
because I don't investigate you know
like uh sponsored by athletic greens
okay it's a nutritional drink should I
investigate them deeply I don't I don't
know you just kind of use reputational
like it seems to work for me should I
like I think I think it really depends
on I think your credibility hit will
depend on what domain you're an expert
in if you're sponsored by a robotics
company
and you're an expert in robotics if that
company turns out to be a disaster and
fraud then you should have looked more
deeply we're talking mostly about like I
hold Tom Brady a lot less accountable
than financial advisors Financial
influencers because that is their world
of expertise and you treat their Rec
recommendation differently
proportionally to what you think their
expertise is so in some ways I don't
actually think Tom Brady I'm sure you
reached a lot of people I personally
didn't feel it all moved by his
recommendation because you know it's
just money
but when you hear somebody who should be
an expert in that thing
endorse a product in that space you hold
that opinion to a higher standard and
when they're completely
cataclysmically wrong
it's going to be a different level of
accountability and I think rightfully so
when um Jim Cramer in was saying bear
Stearns is fine he made that terrible
call and with bear Stearns in 2008. he
was rightfully reamed for all of that
even though it could be considered that
like well you know did he have all the
information maybe not but he's a
financial advisor he does this for a
living if you go on and you make a big
call and you turn out to be wrong and
people lose tons of money
you are going to take a hit I think
rightfully so but no I don't think these
people should go to jail or anything
like that like oh it's such a
complicated thing I mean I just feel it
personally myself I get it but you still
feel the burden of the fact that you're
opinion has influence I know it
shouldn't I know Tom Brady's opinion on
financial investments should not have
influence but it does right that's just
the reality of it right that's a real
burden I didn't know anything about SPF
or FTX it wasn't on my radar at all
um but I could see myself like taking
them on as a sponsor I've seen a lot of
people I respect uh Sam Harris and
others like talk talk with SPF uh like
he's doing good for the world so I could
see myself being Hoodwinked having not
done research and the same thing makes
me wonder
like I I don't want to become cynical
and uh but it makes you wonder who are
the people in your life you trust that
are like that could be the next SPF or
or Worse big powerful leaders Hitler and
all that kind of stuff
um
to what degree do you want to
investigate do you want to uh hold their
feet to the fire see through their
[ __ ] call them on their [ __ ] and
also as a friend if you happen to be
friends or have a connection how to help
them not slip into the land of fraud I
don't know all of this is just
overwhelming yeah I mean I mean we
should be clear like Finance is sort of
a special space
where
you're talking about people's money
you're not talking about whether people
someone takes a bad supplement or like a
supplement that is just they're fifty
dollars out right
I think the scale of harm yeah and
therefore responsibility escalates
depending on what field you're in just
like I wouldn't hold Tom Brady as like
if he gives a bad football opinion right
and he should have known better that is
a different scale of harm than a doctor
giving bad advice right like life's it
like he tells you a pill works and the
pill kills you or something like that
there's just different levels of
accountability depending on the field
you're in and you have to be aware of it
Finance is an extra you have to be
extremely conservative if you're going
to give Financial advice because you're
playing with people's lives and you
cannot play with them half hazardly you
cannot gamble with them you cannot play
with them on a bet because you're
getting paid a lot of money
it's just the nature of the space and so
with the with the space comes the
responsibility and the accountability
and I I don't think you can get around
that who was uh Dan Friedberg that you
mentioned some of these figures in the
SPF around that are interesting to you
super interesting kind of subject
because Dan Friedberg is uh the former
general counsel for ultimate bet
ultimate bet is a was a poker site where
famously they got in a scandal because
uh the owner Russ Hamilton was cheating
with a little software piece of code
they called God Mode God mode allowed
you to see up the guy across from you's
hand obviously you can imagine you can
win pretty consistently if you know
exactly what your opponent has very
unethical
they I should be clear that for some
inexplicable reason I don't think they
were ever charged and convicted of a
crime but they were investigated by a
gambling commission that found they made
tens of millions of dollars this way for
sure
and
Dan Friedberg is the general counsel
he's caught on a call basically
conspiring with Russ to hide this fraud
he's saying we should blame it on a cons
you know a consultant third party and
Russ Hamilton famously says you know
like it was me I did it I don't want to
give the money back
find basically a way to get rid of this
so that's Dan friedberg's big
achievement like that's what he's known
for he's most known for and this is the
guy they pick as their Chief regulatory
officer for FTX why do you hire somebody
who I I get it the not formally charged
and convicted investigated there's all
the and there's tape out there so I want
to be clear about what's actually
available evidence
but someone who's seemingly owned a
cheat only achievement is hiding fraud
why do you hire that guy if the
intention is not to hide is not to hide
fraud so this is a question I put to you
know Sam Bateman freed and his answer
was
well we have a lot of lawyers well and I
said well it's your Chief regulatory
officer he's like well it wasn't we we
did regulate a lot and it was just this
big dance of you know basically he's
done great work he's a great guy and
I think that tells you everything you
need to know and there's figures like
that probably even at the lower levels
like just infiltrate the entire
organization well it's just like why
yeah why wasn't there a CFA why why
wasn't there anyone in that space who
could seemingly
be the eyes that goes holy whatever we
need to we we're in dangerous territory
here right
um so yeah it seems very deliberate I
mean I talked to one FTX employee that
they talked about who's told me they
talked about
taking I think it was taking FTX US
public and Sam was very against the idea
and the employee in retrospect
speculated that it might have been
because you'd face so much scrutiny like
regulation-wise like you'd have to you
know go through a lot like more thorough
audits all that kind of stuff that
basically he knew they would never pass
um so yeah I mean it's it's red flags
all the way down with that guy
and you hope all of them get punished
everyone who knew I mean I think for
sure there are people at FTX who didn't
know I think there are some people at
Alameda who didn't know
with their degree sorry to interrupt but
there's degrees of not knowing yes
there's a looking away when you kind of
know yeah Shady stuff that's still the
same as knowing right that's might be
even worse yeah like I was talking to
one Insider and we were talking about
the insider trading they were telling me
about this insider trading and
I said do you think this was Criminal
and they said it was probably criminal
in hindsight yes
and the question is someone who answers
a question like that what does that like
mean you know like it was probably so
you're right there there are different
degrees I mean I'll say at the most
basic I would be very happy if everyone
who had Direct knowledge went to jail
which I don't think will happen to be
clear I think a lot of people are going
to cut deals prosecutors are going to
cut deals so they actually nail Sam
bankman freed I think that's their only
focus what about his reputation what do
you think about all these interviews
um do you think they are helping him do
you think they're good for the world do
you think they're bad for the world like
what's your sense and like say you get
to sit down interview with him for three
hours
and I'm holding the door closed what uh
what kind of is that a useful
conversation or not or at this point it
should be legal
and that's it I think it's useful I mean
I think with resp it's all it's all
about how you interview them you can
interview someone responsibly you can
interview him irresponsibly I think
we've seen examples of both what's in
irresponsible I keep interrupting you
rudely that's okay no no unacceptable no
no I think it's fine
um there was like a New York Times
interview which
spends an amount of time any amount of
time talking about his sleep and he's
like yeah I'm sleeping great I mean I
think that's so deeply disrespectful to
the victims and especially when you're
you're not even releasing an interview
live it's like you have time to triage
what you're going to talk about why
would you spend any amount of time
talking about the sleep that a fraudster
is get get it's just so weird and well
it's a Castile man in that case
I don't I don't I don't think it turned
out I think that's I think that's I I
think okay here's the thing
I could see myself talking about
somebody's sleep or getting in
somebody's mind if I knew I have
unlimited time with them if I knew I had
like a four hours because you get into
the minds of the person how they think
how they see the world because I think
that ultimately reveals
it's actually really good at lying
it reveals the depths the complexity of
the mind that through like osmosis you
get to understand like this person this
person is not as trivial as you realize
also makes you maybe realize that this
person is has a lot of Hope has a lot of
positive ambition that's like uh that
has developed over their life and then
certain interesting ways things went
wrong yeah it become corrupt and all
that kind of stuff you just that's all
fine but this was this conversation was
not properly contextualized yes in the
world of what he did
it and I you know I've I've asked about
this interview because I was like so
curious it was out of the New York Times
and there was not much mention of fraud
or jail or the the big crimes like
misappropriation of even client assets
it was just sort of this you know Sam
sat down with me he's he's under
investigation but there's not much
specifics and then it's like yeah he's
playing storybook brawl he's sleeping
he's and it's just like okay this isn't
adding to the conversation especially in
the New York Times it's like uh you
should be grilling right right exactly
so
um but as I said I mean it's all range
the gamut and some interviews like some
of it's okay and then some of it's weird
like the Andrew Sorkin interview he
asked some hard-hitting questions which
I really appreciated and then at the end
he goes ladies and gentlemen Sam Beekman
freed and everyone gives like us like an
ovation for
Sam I mean the Steel Man of that of
course is like they're actually
applauding Andrew Sorkin but the way you
like lay it up I wouldn't go like ladies
and gentlemen it's like an Applause line
it's like ladies and gentlemen the
Eagles Elton John Lex Friedman and so to
go to so you have this like deal book
Summit where you have all these
important figures that are positively
important and at the end you have Sam
bangman free to fraudster and yo ladies
and gentlemen Sam Beekman freed
everyone's applauding that I think is a
net like I think that's a negative I
think the way that the Optics of that
just were all wrong and so I think um
yeah you have to be very responsible
I think it's useful going back to how
you can usefully do this you can even
when somebody's determined to lie to you
It's always important to
pin them down to a an accounting of
events because that is unimaginably
helpful when it comes to a prosecutor
trying to prove this guy's guilty is
if you say you didn't do a crime but you
don't tell me any details about it
day of the trial you can basically make
up any story right but if you tell me in
detail where you were that day I can go
hunt down you say you were with Joe I go
hunt down Joe and he says he wasn't with
you boom you've lost credibility and now
you're much more you're much more likely
to be convicted so it's really important
to get sbf's exact accounting of how
things went wrong because right now he's
positioning himself to throw his uh
Alameda CEO Caroline Ellison under the
bus like she did everything she knew
everything I knew nothing
well as Caroline Ellison's going to take
the stand and go well I have all these
text messages and this is all a lie and
then Sam begman freed is going to be
completely
you know
uh ruined like self-ruin by his own
design so I think it's so more like a
legal type of uh like get the details of
where he was what he was thinking what
the I think it's like yeah I think it's
it's public probably cares to get to
know what happened to and again I think
if you're if you're careful
you can expose someone for as they lie
to you without giving in to those lies
right like without capitulating to oh
I'm just going to assume you're correct
I think you can point to well Lex you
say it happened this way but you've lied
about X Y and Z why should we believe
you that's a suddenly a totally
different conversation than just being
like Oh okay that's how it happened the
thing I caught that bothered me
and the thing I hope to do in interviews
if
um if if I eventually get good at this
thing is the human aspect of it which is
like which I think you have to do in
person
is he seems a bit nonchalant about the
pain and the suffering of people
that I have red flags about in the way
he's he communicates about the loss of
money like the pain that people are
feeling about the money I I get red
flags like you're not uh forget if
you're involved in that pain or not
you're not
feeling that pain
well he'll he'll say he is but he'll be
playing a game of League of Legends
while doing it no but I I just see it
from his face I know and that needs to
be grilled yeah like that little human
dance there that's I mean I
um I considered
I talked to him I considered doing an
in-person interview with him
um
and in that are you still considering it
I don't know do you think do you think I
I should in person I think it depends if
you think you have anything to add to
the conversation a lot of people have
yeah there's been already you did an
incredible job thanks
I think I I think I would like to grill
the [ __ ] out of them as a fellow human
yeah but not investigating
yeah yeah like like another human being
another human being who I can have
compassion for who has caused a lot of
suffering in the world
like that that grilling like basically
convey the anger of the people and the
pain that people are feeling
right like that yeah
I think
I think it'd be really hard I mean like
that guy is sort of a master dancer and
what he would say at the end of it
because I've listened to so many
interviews of him
um I probably am like a GPT model for
Sam
I think he would do some kind of thing
about like yeah I really um I really um
hear you and um you know it's it's just
terrible I feel such an obligation to
the people who've lost money and you
know it's just it's a lot of money it's
a lot of money you know you do something
like that and it would be very
superficially like okay
but when you gr when you drill down to
the details of what he did it's just
impossible that he didn't know and one
of the things that I wish I had asked
maybe I can talk about like I wish I had
gone on this just so hard when you're
doing a live interview to kind of focus
on one thing
everyone's asked about the terms of
service so in the terms of service there
was like
we can't touch our funds your funds are
safe we're never going to do anything
with that anytime anyone brings that up
he says oh well there's this other term
to service over here with margin trading
accounts remember we talked about it's a
derivatives platform if you're in our
derivative side
you have you're subject to different
terms of service which kind of lets us
like move your money around with
everyone else okay
so we treat it as one big pool of funds
and that's sort of the explanation of
how this all happened is we had this
huge leverage position and we lost
everything
but what no one has sort of done a good
enough job getting to the heart of is
that this pool of funds never was
segregated properly it was all treated
under the same umbrella of we can use
your funds there was no amount of we
have the client deposits which were just
deposited with us and not like used to
margin trade or do anything over here
These funds over here we have saved they
didn't fundamentally they lied from the
get-go about how they were treating the
most precious assets which is your
customer deposits that you said you
didn't invest clearly you put them all
over here you YOLO gambled them and then
when everyone starts withdrawing from
here they don't have any money over here
so that is like one of the most
fundamental things that I haven't seen
anyone Grill him on and uh the next time
if I get the chance to Ambush them again
that's that's what I'm going to drill
down on because it's impossible for that
not to be fraud
there's no world where you had a pool of
funds over here and now you don't have
them without you somehow borrowing over
here because if you deposited one
Bitcoin and I never sold that Bitcoin
and it's earmarked Lex Friedman and you
come and it's not there something had to
happen right well it says this is so
interesting so for me
the approach that like you said the most
important question of uh because for you
it's like were those funds segregated
for me the question is as a human being
how would you feel if you were observing
that so like
you know that like marshmallow test with
the babies like it's the human thing
it's a human nature question like uh I
can understand there's a pile of money
and you uh
the good faith interpretation is like
well I know what to do with that pile of
money to grow that pile of money let me
just take a little bit of that
like how willing are you to do that kind
of thing how able are you to do that
kind of thing and when [ __ ] goes wrong
what goes through your mind how does it
become corrupted how do you begin to
Lose Yourself how do you uh delegate
responsibility for the failures like as
opposed to getting facts
try to sneak into the human Mind of a
person when they're thinking that
because the facts there's they're gonna
start waffling they're gonna start like
trying to make sure they don't say
anything that gets them incriminated
right but I just I want to understand
the human being there because I think
that indirectly gives you a sense of
where were you in this big picture I
think I've talked to so many people who
have sort of committed some range of
like outright fraud to like misleading
marketing
no one thinks they're a bad person
nobody admits that they did it and they
knew they are almost nobody does there's
actually one funny exception but um
you had a guy who admitted like yeah I
did it it was wrong and uh you know but
I did it and I wanted the money which
was kind of like almost refreshing in
its honesty but um the reason I focus on
like the facts is because
unless you find a bright red line
humans can rationalize anything I can
rationalize any level of like well I did
this because I had the best of
intentions and if you play the intention
game you'll never convict anyone because
everyone has good intentions everyone's
honest everyone's doing the best they
can and got misleaded and got misguided
ultimately you have to drill down to the
concrete and go look
I get it you're just like the last 50
guys that I interviewed you had the best
of intentions it all went wrong I'm very
sorry for you but at the end of the day
there's people hurting and there's
people that have significant damage to
their life because of you what did you
actually do and what can we prove taking
intention out of it taking motivation
out what can we prove that you did that
was unethical illegal or immoral and
like that is
sort of what usually I try to go to
because I will do those human interviews
but
um you know it's just like it's just
it's like the same record on repeat I
mean a lot I gotta the same I I'm with
you I'm with you on the everything you
said but there is ways to do
to avoid the record and repeat I mean
those are different skill set you're
exceptionally good at the investigative
like investigating I do believe there's
a way to break through the the repeat
there's the different techniques to it
yeah one of which is like taking outside
of their particular story yes EV when
everyone looks at their own story they
can see themselves as a good player
doing good but you can do other thought
experiments I mean there's uh but
they'll follow you they'll know what the
thought experiment is no well it depends
it depends my friend I mean the like uh
you know to me there's a million of them
but of just exploring your ethics would
you kill somebody to protect your family
and you explore that you start to sneak
into like what's your sense uh of the
in-group versus the owl group how much
damage you can do to the out group and
who is the out group and you start to
build that sense of the person are we
like the two Mobsters that we're dressed
as do we protect the family and [ __ ]
everyone else you're with us and the
ones who are against us [ __ ] them or do
we have a sense that human human all
human beings are all have value equal
value we want to wear a joint Humanity
there's ways to get to that and you
start to build up this sense of like
some people that make a lot of money are
better than others they deserve to be at
the Top If you have that feeling you
start to get get a sense of like yeah
the poor people are the dumbasses
they're the idiots if you believe that
then you start to understand that this
person may have been at the core of this
whole corrupt organization
yes two things one
I think you should join me on this side
of the table we'll put SPF over here
yeah well good guy bad guy human facts
like you're the bad guy I'm like no no
slow down coffee what is your feeling
about Humanity
yeah have you been getting enough sleep
yeah right obviously so I so I think no
I think there's a lot of Truth to what
you said
one thing I've noticed that is hard to
combat is sort of like preference
falsification and just like just the
outright lying about those things is
tough to kind of pin down but yeah
you're absolutely right there's ways to
interview people there's all sorts of
interesting techniques and yeah I don't
disagree good good cop bad cop we should
do this should be like a sitcom okay you
uh did an incredible documentary on safe
Moon uh the title is I uncovered a
billion dollar fraud uh can you tell me
the story of safe Moon sure so uh safe
moon was a crypto coin that exploded on
the scene in um
2021 I think at this point Sorry I'm
losing track of my years one year in
crypto's like five years in real life
um but it kind of gained a huge amount
of popularity because of this idea that
it's in the name you go safely to the
Moon how they were going to do this is
with sort of a sophisticated smart
contract idea where
there's I kind of have to explain the
way some contracts get rug pulled per
second or there's scams happen so in the
uh sometimes it's called like the [ __ ]
coin space the altcoin space anything
like below Bitcoin ethereum and maybe
the top five or ten is kind of seen as
this Wasteland of gambling and like you
know you don't know if they're the
developers are going to become anything
or not you're kind of like reading the
white paper trying to figure it out so
there's this big question about like how
can you get scammed how can back to the
interests you don't want the developer
to have some like parachute cord where
they can pull all the money out so one
way this happens is that in
decentralized decentralized finance
there's something called the liquidity
pool okay it's basically this big pot of
money that allows people to trade
between two different currencies so
let's say like safe Moon and Bitcoin
right or ethereum or it's actually on
the binance smart chain so it'd be BNB
um and this pool of money can be
controlled by the developers in such a
way they can steal it all right they can
just grab it I don't want to go too much
into details because I feel like I'll
lose people here but the point of safe
moon was the core idea was we're locking
this money up
you can't touch it and actually every
transaction that you buy safe moon with
will take a five percent tax of that
we'll do a 10 tax but five percent of it
will go back to all the holders of safe
Moon okay and five percent of it will go
back into this little pool of money okay
so the idea is as you trade as this
token becomes more viral
two things will happen one the people
who are holding it long term will be
rewarded for holding it long term by
receiving this five percent tax that's
distributed to everyone and two you can
kind of trust that your your money's
gonna have this stable value because
this pool of money here in the middle
that's kind of guaranteeing you can get
your safe Moon out into this actually
valuable currency it's not going to move
so the story of safe moon was that
fundamentally this was not the case uh
they promised that this money was going
to be locked up it was not actually
locked up at all they said it was
automatically locked up you don't have
to worry about it well it was very
manually locked up and they didn't
actually lock a lot of it up
um they took a lot of it for themselves
for the developers so there's a lot of
players in this
um some of the a lot of them have left
by now there's kind of this main CEO
that everyone knows John caroni now and
You know despite saying that they were
going to lock up all the funds for four
years somehow he's gone from as everyone
else in the in the token has lost 99 of
the value of the token so they've lost
99 percent
he's gotten uh like a six million dollar
crypto portfolio multi-million dollar
real estate portfolio invested Millions
into various companies so he's he's
accrued this huge wealth and so I made a
video basically exposing that and
showing how this this coin which once
had a four billion dollar market cap is
just viral everywhere everyone was
talking about it because of these viral
ideas like it is sort of a captivating
idea that by holding it you could get
returns right like you just hold on to
it you automatically get money and it's
a viral idea that this money in the
middle in the pot isn't going to leave
you
when those things turned out to be false
this community has had a slow death as a
lot of people realized it was a scam and
there's been a core part of the
community
which gets to an interesting Dynamic we
can talk about if you want to
where they have like doubled down on the
belief in coroni and so part of it was
out of a hope to let those people know
what was really going on in their coin
and like hopefully save some of them
um
not like some altruistic sense but like
or not like some like I'm like a hero
sense but in the sense of um like I
think a lot of them didn't know like
literally didn't know so just sort of
like as a public service letting them
know so they could get their money out
and hopefully say themselves uh a lot of
pain and suffering so yeah they really
dug in so this is some did some did some
left I mean a lot of people have left
but the people who are left are people
with large amounts of safe Moon Holdings
that are down immensely and you can
imagine at a certain point in losses
there's a tremendous psychological
pressure to go look I'm I'm in it I
gotta go for the Long Haul and then you
want to believe that this thing is
legitimate and will succeed because a
there's an ego component around I
haven't been scammed I'm too smart to
get scammed it's tremendously uh you
know it's it hurts psychologically to
acknowledge you've been taken for a ride
and also you just want this thing to
succeed for your financial well-being so
you like want to believe it so there's
tremendous psychological pressure to
build cult-like communities around these
tokens
and I've noticed with the incentive of
like Community built it's sort of new to
finance there's like these meme coins or
these these Cults I don't want to it's
not really fair to call all of them
Colts like some of them are open to
criticism but one of the things that
defines Cults is they're not open to
sunlight or criticism
there's these Financial communities that
are opening up with crypto with a few
stocks where if you criticize them you
are attacked and the entire Community
has every incentive to kind of like
downplay your legitimate criticisms or
kind of
um go after you and so it creates this
interesting Dynamic that's fascinated by
what do you think about
Bitcoin then
do you think it's one of those
communities that does attack you when
criticized so which I guess which coins
do you think are open to criticism and
which are not it's kind of tough like
like no Community is a monolith so just
like it's just a spectrum of how open
they are there's just like there's
always this core contingent of extreme
believers who will go after anyone who
criticizes them and it's just about how
wide of a band that makes up of the
entire token how intensely how active
that small community is correct so it's
in Bitcoin they're called Bitcoin
maximalists yes but you can also call
any any communities subgroup like that
maximalist whatever the belief is right
I don't know uh Dunkin Donuts Maximus uh
that Community is probably small in
terms of attack you online if you could
you know which Community has a very
intense
following so
I got attacked on the internet when I
said Messi's better than Ronaldo
oh yeah that's controversial and so
that's a very intense maximalist
Community there uh the other one that
surprised me is when I said
now I did it ingest okay folks I said
emacs is a better ID than Vim I love
emacs I agree
listen I have trauma I wake up sweating
sometimes at night thinking Max Master
is the the Vim the Vim people are after
me they're everywhere they're in the
shadows no Vim is an amazing and it's
actually surprised I've recently learned
that it's
um still even more so than before an
incredibly active community so a lot of
people wrote but do you use space Max
it's just emacs and Vim no I haven't I
use raw
um but but so you got to use yeah hold
on a second I actually recently I have
recently said you know what
um Let's Make Love Not War and I went to
vs code
I uh I went to a more modern idea but uh
because I did most of my programming Max
I did most of anything as one does an
emacs just because I also love lisp so I
can customize everything then I realized
like
like how long will vim and emacs be
around really well I was thinking as a
programmer
looking like 10 20 years out
you know I should challenge myself to
learn new ideas to learn uh the the new
tools that the majority of the community
is using so that I can understand what
are the benefits of the cost I found
myself getting a little too comfortable
with the tools that I grew up with sure
I think one of the fundamental ways of
being as a programmer is anyone involved
with technology
based on how quickly it's evolving is to
keep learning new tools like the way of
life should be constantly learning
you're not a mathematician or a
physicist or any of those disciplines
that are more stable this is like
everything's changing cryptos like you
said a perfect example that you have to
constantly update your understanding of
the of of digital Finance constantly in
order to be able to function in order to
be able to criticize it uh in order to
be able to know what to invest in so
yeah that that was why I did uh I tried
pie charm a bunch uh the whole jet
Brands uh uh infrastructure and then
also vs code because that's really
popular I mean you know Adam and um uh
Sublime of those I've been I've been
exploring I've been exploring UCS code
is amazing you should check out space
Max I'm just gonna give one more pitch
for it it's just basically like a
customizable customizable configuration
well emacs is already customizable but
it's uh
it's pretty useful I'm not even much of
a coder but for like certain journaling
applications or like time management
like I find it really useful so
but anyway we're so like in I feel like
half this podcast is what it should have
been and then half of it's just us
nerding out about our own engineering
like idiosyncrasies sorry sorry guys
um all right so what were we talking
about safe Moon
and Bitcoin Bitcoin what do you think is
there uh
have you made enemies
in certain communities what do you think
about Bitcoin so
I've made certain enemies in the sort of
crypto Skeptics space because there's
sort of this range of skepticism you can
have about cryptocurrency I'm obviously
a skeptic of a lot of it
um but there are certain aspects of
crypto that I think are inevitable and
I'm gonna do my best to kind of describe
those here but I'm not committed to any
crypto specifically but there are some
I've taken a lot of heat ironically for
not being skeptical enough there's some
people who believe that like the entire
thing is a complete waste of time their
uh our slash but coin on Reddit it's an
amazing Community actually it's very
funny they have what's a book it's like
is it it's like a play on bitcoin
they're like oh they're just like oh at
least we admit it's a scam very funny
guys uh very funny people there so but
they like but they'll they'll be like
you know coffee's Alicia just admit that
all of it's a giant Ponzi scheme all of
it's a basically like not real so
everything including Bitcoin include
yeah it's all it's all basically all the
Ponzi nomics it's all it's it's
ponzienomics all the way down it's like
there is no fundamental use case that uh
is that useful I don't know if I guess I
don't want to straw man them here I
don't want to say that I don't know if
they're saying that it's all useless at
minimum they're saying the level of
interest in cryptocurrencies is far the
actual usefulness of it is far less than
the amount of attention and time and
money that's being poured into it so
like the revolutionariness of this
technology is not at all revolutionary
let me kind of Steal man what I think
the pro crypto take is
I think
that
Technologies are sort of this inert
thing and the success of them in my
opinion is not based on PR it's not
based on marketing it's based on cheaper
faster better
fundamentally the success of any
technology relies on those three things
and longevity of it
so I have two employees and both of them
are out of the country so I have to
frequently make international wire
payments to them
um is one of them SBF just as a reporter
I have to ask no okay all right um he's
not an apparel yeah I think he'd have to
pay me I'm trying to do my best coffee
Zillow where it's again hard hitting
yeah investigative questions good so
with these International payments you
face all sorts of slow
fees and you you face like kind of like
this time thing and it's this painful
process
so
if I use different cryptocurrencies some
of them are like really fast some of
them have really low fees I just believe
in a world where
digital currencies with fast payments
with cheap payments revolutionize
the global exchange of currency and I
don't know if this if this is going to
include the blockchain
it's just that the blockchain is the
first thing that's really embraced truly
digital currency which doesn't need to
go through this complicated system of
wire transfers and just happens so I can
send you let's say I want to send you
ethereum or Bitcoin I can send it to you
just as fast if I send you a dollar
or a billion dollars and I can send it
to you just as fast if you're across
from me or if you're across the world
from me that I think is a step change
and easier faster better in terms of
like just this really basic
International payments kind of idea so I
think at like its core if the the lowest
form use case of cryptocurrencies is
that I think it will
um change the world in some variety it's
just kind of the larger question is is
that gonna is that technology going to
include the blockchain specifically
or not the other benefit is transparency
which I personally like as an
investigator it's just that
previously it's like hard to describe
how opaque our financial system is until
you've tried to investigate someone or
something
understanding finances unless you have a
subpoena unless you're like the FBI or
like the SEC and you can get a subpoena
for someone's finances or you're going
through Discovery you don't know what
someone has you're basically playing
poker with everyone and the cards are
face down
For the First Time The blockchain to
some extent because there are ways to
obfuscate it and in some ways
cryptocurrency has enabled more fraud
which is kind of this irony but in some
ways it's enabled people to also audit a
lot better and in real time and I think
that is a structural change
that is fundamentally for the better
the question of all this is do those
Bettors outweigh the cons that this
introduces and how much can those can
regulation mitigate those cons some of
those cons being like fraud money
laundering all these negative
externalities that are easier with
cryptocurrency what do you think
cryptocurrency in particular seems to
attract fraudulent people uh like uh
scammers and because it Fosters and
because it's unregulated it's the wild
west and you can transmit large amounts
of money very quickly across the world
what about with very little oversight
creating new crypto projects like uh new
coins uh because you have to show very
little actual use case you can just
promise this is like true of any
emerging technology so much vaporware
happens at the beginning when it's all
promise because fundamentally let's say
you're legitimate I'm illegitimate
we look the same at the start of a
technology because both of us are
promising what this can do and in fact
the less Scruples and morals I have in
some ways I can now compete you because
I can say mine does what Lexus does but
like way better and way faster and it's
going to happen in a year rather than 10
years you're being honest I'm playing a
dishonest game I look better once this
space matures and you actually have some
people actually doing the things that
they say they're going to do suddenly
this equation changes now your Amazon
you're delivering in two days I can say
whatever I want
you do the thing you do and I have no
credibility so I think the like part of
part of the fraud is you know just the
ability to transmit so much money so
quickly with such little oversight part
of it is like this just happens with any
emergent technology vaporware is a real
thing and hopefully as the space matures
as regulation comes in
things will improve
let me ask you your own psychology sure
you're going after
some of the richest some of the most
powerful people in the world do do you
worry about your own Financial legal and
psychological well-being
uh yes
yeah I do I mean I'm not totally
oblivious to the precariousness
of like any kind of Journalism like this
obviously there's risks I've always
believed
there's a quote and I'm going to butcher
it but I hope you guys understand the
spirit of it
um
you know news is when you print
something someone else doesn't want you
to print everything else is public
relations
I really believe to do meaningful
journalism
you have to go after people like it's
not inherently a safe profession I mean
if you're going to do important work you
have to have risk tolerances and I think
everyone has a line of what that risk
tolerance is
and it's different for everyone I don't
think I could do what Edward Snowden did
I think that would be my bright red line
is going against my own government
it's such a in my opinion I really see
him as a hero like it's such a selfless
Act of self-destruction you know that
the the party you're going after has all
the power and will crush you
and you do it anyway out of the like the
true I don't know platonic ideal of
Journalism I think that's beautiful I
don't think I could do that I think I
need some ability to live and subsist in
the society that I am in
and I think my bright red line would be
like if I'm forced to flee the country
for my work I think I'd finally have to
say no but
for as journalists go I'm pretty risk I
take risk pretty well
um I especially like think risk is
important to take when you're young and
when you can do that I think when I have
I mean I'm married so when I have a
family I think I will probably dial this
risk thing down just being honest I mean
I think you kind of have to
um but right now I mean I'm kind of like
running on all cylinders I'm willing to
take on quite a quite a range of people
but um well you speak a lot about it
wolf pack of one or small yeah wolf pack
as opposed to having like a New York
Times behind you or a huge organizations
with lawyers with a team with a history
with these people are less courageous
this is the this is the dirty truth the
bigger the organization the more
conservative a lot of them are it's true
that sometimes they like and this is not
to bash big organizations I'm just
saying this is an observation of someone
who's talked to a lot of people and
especially in the world of fraud a lot
of them are scared to engage
in fraud that is obvious but hasn't been
litigated yet this is why you'll never
see documentaries about ongoing fraud on
Netflix it's too much of a liability
they'll Sue Netflix to hell and they
know that if they win Netflix has the
money to pay it so corporations like the
New York Times you know a lot of these
some of them are very Cur like they're
as courageous as they can be but at the
bottom line if someone sues you to hell
and back and you have to pay up you will
disappear and you're relying on
liability insurance which you're already
paying out the ask for to try to cover
you if you get sued but if you get sued
even if you win that liability insurance
now goes up in price the next year and
if you're the New York Times it goes up
by a lot so I mean
um I think there's work that independent
journalists can do uniquely that
they can actually take like in some ways
more risk than a giant institution which
has a lot more in my sense to lose even
though it would appear like they have
more in terms of Defense too but you get
uh you can be bullied legally yeah do
you get afraid of that sure I mean
I just uh
all these things are things you have to
be aware of and then forget to do your
job like you have to be you know it's
like it's like being like a snowboarder
and it's like do you realize you could
hit your head and it's like yeah of
course but in order to go do the like
the flip or whatever you have to just
accept the risk
mitigate the risk as much as possible
and move on so we have
um we have like insurance we keep like a
pool of funds for that kind of thing
like I'm very conservative with how I I
spend my money basically all on
production and like trying to make my
life as secure as I can and then I just
do the work that I you know I I want to
do because
so 99 of your fund goes into the in the
studio into the studio and then into
into that
elaborate space of yours yeah of course
um
how many kittens have to die to
manufacture that studio but anyway
that's that's my investigation for later
um
what what keeps you mentally strong
through all of this what's your source
of mental like strength of your
psychological strength through this
uh I think there was a time when I was
getting a lot of cease and desists some
people were like actually like like
saying like they're gonna show up to my
house all that kind of stuff I don't
think I was that um I think I was pretty
worried about that for a while my wife
was a huge source of strength here where
she was like hey if you're not
comfortable with it you need to get out
of the game or you need to basically
like suck it up and like this is what it
is if you're going to go after these
people you have to basically
um be mentally strong around this and
seeing her
have that realization helped me have the
same realization and I really deeply
admire and respect that about her and it
solved a lot of my concerns around that
it's just it just made me realize
every profession has risks it is what it
is you mitigate and then you move on
why do you think there's so few
journalists like you
you you're basically the embodiment at
least in the space you operate of what
great journalism should be
why do you think there's very few like
you
that's such an enormous compliment and
probably overstatement but
um
I first want to pay respect there are a
lot of great journalists and a lot of
them
are like I don't want to just kind of
take it and go yeah you know it's just
me there's so many great journalists
Matt Levine Kelsey Piper
um you know you've got Anonymous
journalists like Dirty Bubble you've got
citizen journalist like Tiffany Fong but
yeah but
I think
if you're going to be in the space in
the long term you do need to accept
certain risks and I think in the long
term it's like
I don't know how easy it is to play that
game for a long period of time
because you make
to do great journalism you don't get
paid a lot compared to what you could
get paid if you did press pieces or
anything like that
you take a lot of risks legally you take
physical risks you take
it's just like if you care about money
it's not the profession
and I feel like
a lot of people when they get notoriety
they move to like well I can just
maximize the money security side of
things and I think it takes out a lot of
would-be great journalists
and also so first of all comfort of a
physical and mental well-being yes and
also being invited to parties of
powerful people uh you um
you make enemies rich and Powerful
enemies doing this
yes
but that's why it makes it
that's why it's admirable I mean you
know it's it's an interesting case study
that you've been doing it as long as you
have
and I hope you keep doing it but it's
just interesting that it's rare
I'll say
I want to make a call like I think
societies can create
better journalists and worse journalists
insofar as they support the journalists
who are doing great work and I want to
call out Edward Snowden specifically
because what we have done to him is such
a travesty and the only lesson you can
learn if you're a logical human being is
that you should never whistle blow on
the United States Government after
looking at what they did to Snowden so
as a society
we can put pressure on lawmakers to make
it easier for people to do the great
work
by not punishing the people who do great
work if that makes sense and de-risking
it for them because we shouldn't expect
journalists to be martyrs to do great
work right to do important work and part
of that comes from protecting
whistleblowers there's like very common
sense things I love like it's great to
heroicize you know people like Edward
Snowden and stuff like that but we
shouldn't expect them to be heroes to do
that work do you ever think about going
you've been focused on financial fraud
do you ever think about going about
after other centers of power
uh like uh government government
politics politics it seems to me you
can't do good work
um like everybody doing good work in
politics is to some extent from my
limited perspective as I as I said I'm
not that into it it seems like everyone
has to take a side because even if you
do great work whoever you're exposing
half the other people no matter how good
your work is are going to claim it's
just for partisan hackery and they're
going to malign you so it seems like
a lot of journalists have to take a
slant even if it's not explicit like
bias they have to take a slant on who
they expose I hate that I would really
like a world where you could freely
expose both sides without having a
constant malignment of like you know or
who are you working for or you did this
for XYZ or whatever like I really find
that deeply problematic about our
current uh like
journalism in the political sphere as
far as Government stuff I think it's
easy to do not easy but like it's much
more
enticing to do foreign journalism than
to do local journalism on positions of
power because if you question
it's so easy to just get the bigger you
the bigger cases you expose locally
you're you get in danger like it's just
like very very clear-cut the bigger the
case the more your your financial
well-being your access your entire life
is like sort of in Jeopardy whereas if
you do foreign journalism you can do
great work and largely you're protected
by your own government so it's kind of
this weird thing where if you want great
journalism on America sometimes going
abroad might be
but the politician thing this that's
interesting you mentioned that and going
abroad
I think the way you think about your
current work I think applies in great
journalism in in politics as well so
what happens I I have that sense
because I aspire to be like you in the
in the sort of in the conversation space
of like uh with politicians I tried to
talk to people on the left and the right
and do so in a nonpartisan way and
criticize but also steal men in their
cases what happens I've learned is when
you talk to somebody on the right
the right kind of brings you in it's
like yes we'll keep you comfortable come
with us and then the left attacks you
and and so uh and the same happens on
the left you talking on the left the
right attacks you yeah and the left as
they come with us so like there's a
there's a Temptation and uh a momentum
to staying to that one side whatever
that side is
um the same with foreign journalism you
can cover Putin critically there's a
strong pull to being pro Ukraine
prosolinski Pro
basically really covering in a favorable
way to the point of propaganda to the
point of PR the zelenski regime if you
criticize the landscape regime there's a
strong pull towards then being
supportive of not necessarily the Putin
regime but a very different perspective
on it which is like NATO is the one that
created that war there's a there's a
there's narratives that pull you and
what I think a great journalist does is
make enemies and plus size and walk
through through that fire and not get
pulled in to the protection of anyone's
side because it gets so harshly attacked
anytime they deviate from the center
well and I think also like
there's a criticism of all centrists
which I think in some way is fair and I
say that to someone largely who's this
interest which is that this what about
is or like this like what about the left
or what about the right can skew
when it's not a one it's not a both
sides issue
so in the case of like Russia Ukraine I
think like I'm strongly in favor of
Ukraine even though I tend to go like on
both sides and that might be partly
because one of my employees is Ukrainian
um and I think
what a great journalist does especially
like in politics is I think they
criticize
the regime that's most in Power most
controls the keys and is the most
corrupt at that time and they might
appear to be like let's say during the
realm of trump
a great journalist would criticize Trump
but that same journalist who held
Trump's feet to the fire should be
capable of holding Biden's feet to the
fire four years later if that kind of
makes sense that's exactly right yeah
yeah so any uh revealing any so
attacking any power center for the
corruption for the flaws they have uh
irrespective of like your political
agenda or your political ideas
yeah so that and that's what I mean
about sort of the war in Ukraine there
are several key players NATO
Russia Ukraine China uh
India
I mean there's several less uh important
players maybe some of the like Iran and
like Israel and maybe Africa
and what great journalism take requires
is basically revealing the flaws of each
one of those players irrespective of the
attacks you get and you're right that
throughout any particular situation
there is some some parties that are
worse than others and you have to
um weigh your perspective accordingly
but also it requires you to be Fearless
in certain things like for example I
don't even know
what it's like to be a journalist
covering China now
oh that's an exact case of like China
has made it so difficult to be a good
journalist that they've effectively
squashed criticism because to be a
journalist in China means constantly
risking your life every single day to
criticize that government and so the
best journalists are a lot of times
outside the country or they have sources
inside the country who are like there's
like this you know
different there's layers to the
journalism where there's insiders who
are leaking information but they
themselves cannot publish because it's
like it's you know it's it's extremely
risky so
yeah I think I think as a society one
measure of how healthy the political
structure is is how well you can
criticize it without fearing for your
safety
in that sense the chaos and the
bickering going on in the United States
politics is a good thing that people can
criticize very harshly very harsh and be
in terms of safety are pretty safe yes
absolutely I think our only challenge is
like where it gets dangerous is around
like top secret information the
government comes down so hard that
the danger in in covering politics here
is you can expose something that's top
secret that should be exposed and
they'll ruin you so that's where you
again give props to Snowden for stepping
up 100 100 what's uh the origin of of uh
the suspender wearing Batman what how
did you come to do what you do like what
we talked about where you are and how
your mind works but how did it start
I've kind of always been interested in
fraud or or at least I saw fraud early
on and I was just like curious about
what is this I didn't know what I was
really looking at so basically my mom
got cancer when I was in high school and
it was pretty traumatic I mean she's
fine she had thyroid cancer which is I
we didn't know it at the time it's like
Cancer's cancer but it's fairly easily
treatable with surgery uh it's one of
the better you know survivable ones and
I just watched her get like bombarded
with all these like phony Health scams
of you know just like colloidal silver
you know all these different like
remedies and she was very into you know
all the different ways that she might
treat her cancer obviously surgery is
very daunting and you know I was just
confused I was like why are we doing so
many different remedies that all seem a
very dubious health value
later I'd find out that these are like
all grifters I mean they take advantage
of free speech in America to like
advertise their products as you know
life-saving Miracles whatever when
they're of course not
um eventually she got the surgery thank
God but I know people in my life who
their parents passed away because
because they didn't have the surgery
they instead
took the alternative option I know like
I don't want to go into specifics
because I don't want to mention their
specific like case but their uh family
member went to Mexico for some alternate
treatment health treatment instead of
getting an easy surgery and they died
and so it's like
I realized you know where is the outrage
about this where's the who covers this
stuff and I realized well not many
people do then I went to college I was
getting a chemical engineering degree
and all my friends were like telling me
you know hey you should come to this
meeting you know we don't need this like
you're doing this engineering stuff
that's great you're going to make like
70k a year but don't you want to get
like rich now like why wait till you're
60 years old to retire like you can be
rich now Lex so
I'd go show up to a hotel and there'd be
an MLM like multi-level marketing you
know pitch for uh Amway or whatever it
was that day and
I was once again fascinated I didn't
know what I was looking at but I was
like what is this weird game we're all
playing where we sit in this room we're
looking at the speaker who says he's so
successful right but why is he taking a
Friday or a Saturday to do this you know
pitch at night and they're going to
telling me I'm going to be financially
free but they're working on their
Saturday and Sunday and so it's like how
financially free are they so just like
confused I was like you know none of my
friends were Rich they all said they
were going to be rich no one ever seemed
to get rich and so I was sort of baffled
by what I was looking at later I
graduate I had no interest in doing
engineering which we can kind of get
into but I want to do something in media
um and I started covering a variety of
topics but eventually I sort of
Revisited this interest in fraud and I
started talking about these kind of get
rich quick grifters that were online
sort of the the Tai Lopez variety you
know 67 steps or you know whatever like
five steps to get rich five coins to
five million you know these get rich
quick schemes that a lot of people were
interested in no one seemed to get rich
once again except for the people at the
tippity tippity top selling the get rich
quick thing and I was like fascinated by
the structure of it I was like does
nobody see what this is like does nobody
get it so I started making a series of
videos on that and the response was like
palpable I mean it was like I've made a
lot of stuff before that I had made
stuff that got a million views I'd had
like some marginal success but the
response of like the emails that came in
the I could tell this work even though
it had far less views at the time was
having a different level of impact
that's what I was really interested in
one of my problems with engineering was
from my standpoint I did chemical
engineering at Texas A M
and like I was like is my future just
going to be in a chemical plant
improving some process by two percent
and it's like my gift to the world like
I just I didn't see the hard impact and
that maybe that's a lack of imagination
because chemicals matter but I needed I
wanted to see an impact in the world and
so when like I did started doing this
fraud stuff exposing fraud I like
clicked in my brain I was like whoa this
is kind of doing what I want to do and
so I started posting videos at first it
really focused on like get rich quick
scheme grifty advertising which I think
is super predatory and we can go into
why but um it eventually graduated to
crypto and
it's snowballed I guess because now
we're talking to sambang and freed
okay grifty advertising so actually
there's a step back what is a
multi-level marketing scheme
like what
because I've I've experienced a similar
thing it's like I I remember I worked at
I sold women's shoes at Sears uh in a
bank and I just remember like some kind
of I forgot the name of the company but
you like you can sell like knives or
whatever like that's a couple oh uh I
know what you're talking about I'm like
I'm sure there's a lot of things like
this right and I remember feeling a
similar thing like why
to me what was fascinating about it is
like wow like human civilization is a
interesting like a pyramid scheme like I
didn't maybe didn't know the words for
that but it's like it's cool like you
can like get in a room and you convince
each other ideas and you have these
Ambitions there's a general desire
especially when you're young to like
like life sucks right now nobody
respects you you have no money you want
to do good and you want to be sold this
dream of like if I work hard enough at
this weird thing I can shortcut and get
to the very top yes I don't know what
that is and it I also in me felt that
like life really sucks and I could do
good and I'm a lucky I I found a way to
do good I'm like and I don't know you
connect with that somehow I think
there's like this weird fire inside
people to like to make better of
themselves right I don't know if it's
just an American thing or if it but
anyway that was fascinating to me from a
human nature perspective grifter's play
on this though right like this is so the
best salesmen play on true narratives
that you already believe so the true
narrative is you know life is unfair it
is tough
um The American Dream as described by go
to a job work at the same company for 40
years and then retire to a safety net
that you're positive is going to be
there that is largely dead and so they
like play on those fears and those
problems to then sell you a pill a
solution a thing and this the problem is
that is that the solution is usually
worse than even the problem they
sketched out like you will do better
most of the time by going with the
regular company than you will by going
with these goofy multi-level marketing
but let me answer your question what is
a multi-level marketing so
there's a criticism first of all that um
well let me get to what it is in theory
like at its most ideal multi-level
marketing is where you have a product
that you're selling and one of the ways
you help sell it is by rather than going
through traditional marketing like where
you go and you put out print advertising
it's like sort of a social network of
marketing I sell to you and it actually
Lex not only can I sell to you you can
then go sell this product and you'll
make money selling it and you know what
to incentivize me to get other salesmen
because when I get another salesman I'm
actually giving myself competition so
that's bad so to incentivize me to do
that they'll pay me part of what you
make right and then you go out and you
go okay well I can sell this product I
also can get new salesmen to like sell
for me and I'm gonna make money from you
whatever so it goes down the line of you
create multiple levels where you can
profit from their marketing right
the problem with this system is that
however well-intentioned it is is that
usually the emphasis of that selling and
making money ends up not being about the
product at all and ends up entirely
being about recruiting new people to
recruit new people to recruit new people
that's the real way to make money in
multi-level marketing this is where the
very true criticism of most multi-level
marketing if not all are pyramid schemes
in structure because what a pyramid
scheme is is it's all about I put in 500
and I recruit two people to put in 500
and that comes up to me and they put in
they get two people to put in 500 and it
goes to them and the reason it's a it's
a flawed business model is in order for
it to work and everyone to make money
you'd have to assume an infinite human
race and so that's not the case most
people end up getting screwed in
multi-level marketing and in pyramid
schemes
that's what that is that's that thing
and the quality of the product it
doesn't necessarily matter where you're
selling to people who are financially
incentivized to like buy this thing yeah
and so you're um
you're selling the dream of becoming
rich yes to the people down in the
pyramid that's the real product of
multi-level marketing unfortunately
um and so you look at the statistics of
these companies and although they'll
make it seem like it's so easy to be the
top you know point one percent who's
making all this money the statistics are
that 97 make less than a minimum wage
doing this they spend an enormous amount
of time and just what's so cruel about
it is that's not advertised up front I
mean it's like if I go at work at
McDonald's I know what I'm getting if I
go work at Amway I have visions of
they've sold me visions of beaches and
whatever and more than likely I'm losing
money so better than 50 of people lose
money but 97 of people make less than
minimum wage it's like it's such a bad
business uh for the vast majority of
people who join it and the people at the
very top who are lying to the people at
the bottom saying they all can do it
when they can't
are making all the money so it's it's
yeah it's really messed up and the
interesting thing of of noticed maybe
myself too because I've participated in
the knife selling for like a short
amount of time that's probably the
experience that most people from Cutco
is it
I don't know I don't think it was Cutco
I I know what you're talking about it's
killing me but I think there are several
variations of it I think I was part of
an
um
uh less popular one it doesn't like you
keep wanting to say it was called Vector
yeah yes I I something with a B was what
I was gonna say it might be Vector
um yeah I get what you're saying though
it's a multi-level marketing knife
selling but the the thing is I just
remember my own small experience with it
is I was too I was embarrassed at myself
for having like participated
I think there's an embarrassment that's
why you that's why people down in the
pyramid don't like speak about it right
that your part like I don't I'm trying
to understand the aspects of human
nature that facilitate this well this is
one of the problems with fraud is
there's a tremendous embarrassment to
being had yeah also if you buy so
slightly different human nature is that
if you buy into a get rich quick scheme
and then it doesn't deliver you're more
likely to blame yourself than blame the
product for not actually working you go
well there must be something flawed with
me that's true and they constantly
reinforce this they go well it's all
about your hard work the system works
look at me I did it so if you're failing
it must be some indictment of your
character and you have to always double
down you have to dub the system can't be
flawed you must be flawed and so yeah
it's it's a really messed up system it
really preys on people's psychology to
to keep them in this Loop and that's why
in some ways these things are so viral
even though they don't actually get most
people a significant amount of wealth
and they cost most people money so it's
very unfortunate most people do have the
dream of becoming rich most young people
right and the thing is is that everyone
knows in business what do you sell you
sell solutions to problems so if so many
young people want to get rich the
product is that pitch it's you sell them
the dream why this gets so grifty and so
cruel and predatory is because there is
no easy solution to this there is no
solution that people are going to buy
um because the real solution people want
is no work no education no skills
required no money up front and people
will pay any price for that magic pill
and people are happy to sell that magic
pill
and I think those people are very cruel
and I think deserve to get exposed for
it so somebody that's been criticized
for MLM type schemes is uh Andrew Tate
yeah uh somebody that I'm very likely to
talk with so sure people who have been
telling me that I'm too afraid to talk
to Andrew Tate first let me just say I'm
not a
afraid to talk to anyone it's just that
certain people require preparation and
you have to like allocate
your life in such a way that you want to
prepare properly for them sure and so
you have to kind of think uh who you
want to prepare for because I have other
folks that have more power than this
particular figure that I'm preparing for
so you have to make sure you uh allocate
your time wisely but I do think he's a
very influential person
that raises questions of what it means
to be a man in the 21st century
um
and that's a very important and
interesting question because young
people look up to philosophers to
influencers about what it means to be a
man they look up to Jordan Peterson they
look up to Andrew Tate they looked up to
others to other figures I think it's
important to
talk about that to uh think what does it
mean to be a good man in the Society of
course in the other gender there's the
same question what does it mean to be a
good woman I think obviously the bigger
question is what does it mean to be a
good person but
um okay
uh so and that said one aspect of the
criticism that Andrews received yeah is
not just on the misogyny is on the MLM
aspect of the multi-level marketing
schemes data so is is there some truth
to that is there some fraudulent aspect
to that so yeah I I definitely think so
I mean that's the main reason I
criticized him
um
so let's back up there's a few
clarifications I need to make what
Andrew Tate is selling is not
multi-level marketing although he is
selling the dream he's selling an
affiliate marketing thing which is
slightly different so in multi-level
marketing if I sell to you and then you
go sell to two other people I make money
from those two other people down the
chain multi-level affiliate marketing is
sort of like one level I only make money
so Andrew Tate had this affiliate
program where if you sold Hustler's
University to somebody else which sounds
like something people would Boomers
would put on Facebook in like 2010 like
I went to Hustler's University
um School of Hard by the way you or a
member of Hustler's universities yeah I
joined I joined I became a hustler
that's that's in large part due to my
why I'm so successful is because of my
Hustler University membership I'm just
kidding
um but so it's an affiliate program so
you'd sell like I sell to you this 50
course and I make like five dollars and
Andrew Tate in perpetuity makes 50 a
month off of you okay
what does this course actually sell
right because ultimately he's selling
the dream he's selling hey The Matrix
has enslaved you he's really gone down
this like Neo Rabbit Hole
um so the Matrix has enslaved you your
life is controlled by these people who
want to keep you like kind of weak you
know lazy whatever you need a breakout
and you need to achieve
the the new dream which is sort of like
hustling your way to the top you don't
need the Antiquated systems of of school
you can just pay me 50 a month and I
will teach you everything okay so what
do you actually get well and why is it a
scam so you actually I think it's just a
scam in terms of like value and like
you're selling based on these completely
unrealistic things he's like let's get
rich okay
you get a series of Discord rooms so you
do you know what Discord most people
know what Discord is it's like a bunch
of you know chat rooms basically right
so it's like AOL or is it like yeah yeah
right right well I'm talking to the guy
who who uh quit emacs so I don't know
there's Discord servers and in these
like there's like there's like seven uh
different rooms you can go in or there's
several rooms and each one is like a
different field of making money yes
e-commerce trading cryptocurrency
um I think
fulfillment by Amazon
like copywriting
okay so I went to all of these I checked
them out I checked all their money
making tools the first funny thing is
that Andrew Tate is nowhere to be found
the supposed successful guy that you
like bought into is nowhere to be found
it's these professors that you have now
he has hired and said these guys are
super qualified
so like looked up some of what that some
of these guys have done and some of them
have launched like scammy crypto coins
the cryptocurrency professor was like
Shilling a bunch of coins that did bad
and then like deleted the tweets I mean
just completely he exactly what you'd
expect behind the paywall is nothing of
substance you're not going to learn to
get rich by Escaping The Matrix and
going to work for Jeff Bezos fulfillment
by Amazon is not Escaping The Matrix
right like that's not the way to hustle
to the top it's literally a field of
making money that everyone in the world
has access to if you want to
differentiate yourself and make money
the first thing you realize is going
into skill sets that literally anyone
with an internet account can do is a bad
way to do that because you have to have
some differentiating factor to add value
so it's just such a
obvious and complete scam because there
is no value to this like so-called
education the professors are crap
the advice they're like hiding some of
the bad things they've done and agitates
nowhere to be found ultimately that's
why everyone joins what he's done is
very interesting because
and I'll give him Credit in his
marketing he's been very Savvy to like
make the reasons you admire him not the
thing he's sort of selling which is
weird like he's selling get rich quick
which seems like it relates to his
persona but is actually very orthogonal
to it his Persona is like the tell it
how it is
like tall buff rich guy it's like
actually his Persona that you're buying
into and then he's selling you this
thing to the side which when people get
in there and they're not delivered on
the product he still is those things
that you first thought he was so it's
like I think it's to some extent he's
made a lot of
money by making the thing that he makes
money on not the thing he gets so much
pushback online for and what he's also
loved for so people will push back for
his misogyny but the real way he's
making money is just like basic get rich
quick schemes that are super obvious to
spot but everyone's distracted by like
oh he said some crazy stuff about women
or you know all these various other
scandals he's gotten himself in to get
more and more and more attention so with
the persona
uh is the Hustler University still
operating I think they've rebranded it
I'm part of their pitch now I'm like
they put me on as like I mean as like
the Matrix is trying to take us out Lex
and then it's me saying like you know
they put me in like saying I'm part of
the Matrix they put me in saying oh this
guy sucks you know I joined it sucks and
so they'll play that and they do like a
bass drop and it's like you know
don't listen to people like this I mean
it's I'm basically like uh by The Matrix
to attack yes you're an Insider threat
that infiltrated right now is being used
by The Matrix to attack him well uh to
everyone who criticizes him as part of
the Matrix he won't say who the Matrix
is it's just it's just the shadowy cabal
of Rich powerful people it's just like
the easy narrative for people who are
disaffected and who feel cheated by the
system you just collectivize that system
and you make it the bad guy and you go
look look those guys those guys have
been cheating you they're the bad guys
they want me
shut up and then now the person that the
people who harmed you they want this guy
shut up you're going to listen to him so
that's like it's like the most basic
psychological manipulation that everyone
seems to constantly fall for it's it's
really a trivial and stupid but can you
still man
the case for Hustler's University where
it's actually uh giving young people
confidence
uh teaching and valuable lessons about
like actually incentivizing them to do
something like fulfillment by Amazon the
basic thing to try it sure to learn
about it to fail or maybe see like to
try to give a a catalyst and uh
incentive to try these as much as it
pains me I will try to give a uh a
succinct
maybe Steel Man of it as best as I can
thinking that it's such a grift but um I
think what you would say is that
some people in order to make a change in
their life need a someone who they can
look up to
and men don't have a lot of like strong
role models
like big male presences in their life
who can serve as a proper example so the
most charitable interpretation would be
Andrew Tate
would encourage you to go Reach for the
Stars I guess my problem is I have a
deep like I have a deep issue with the
like lust and greed that centers all
these things it's like this
glorification of
wealth equals status wealth equals good
person wealth and Bugatti equals you are
meaningful you matter and like the dark
underlying thing
is that none of that none of that
matters like none it matters that you
make a decent living but past just like
that I think the like lust for more
stuff and the idolization of these
people that is just like opulence is a
net bad so that's like my steel man has
to stop there because I really disagree
with like the values that are pushed by
people like that yeah no I agree that
that's the thing that should be
criticized I shouldn't say it doesn't
matter I think it's uh just like a an
amazing meal at a at a great restaurant
that matters it's money and Bugattis for
many people make life beautiful like
those are all components but I think
money isn't the you can also enjoy a
beautiful life on a hike in nature you
can
um there's a lot of ways to enjoy life
and one of the deepest has been tested
through time is the intimacy close
connection friendship with other people
or with a loved one they don't talk
about like love yeah what what it means
to be deeply connected with another
person is just like get women get money
all those kinds of things but that yeah
that I think I don't want to dismiss
that because there's like value in that
there's fun in that I think the the
positive I don't I haven't investigated
Hustler's University but the positive I
see in general is young people
don't get much respect from society
uh that's easy to call it the Matrix and
so on but there's a kind of uh dismissal
and of them as human beings as if
capable of contributing of of doing
anything special and then here's you
have young people who are sitting there
broke
um with big dreams they need the mentors
they need somebody to inspire them so
like
um I would criticize the flawed nature
of the message sure but also it's just
like you have to realize like there
needs to be
institutions uh or people or influencers
that help like Inspire right the problem
is though is the people who are pitching
unrealistic versions of that
are getting a lot of attention whereas
like there's so many great free courses
where you can learn everything and more
about
fulfillment by Amazon or about
copywriting or all these different
things that I think like so often the
air is just the oxygen is sucked up by
all the grifters who promise everything
it's back to what we said about
vaporware this is one of the reasons
that
um like educational products can so
often be co-opted by grifters is
vaporware is very hard to distinguish
because
prom like the feedback loop on education
is not clear it's not obvious
immediately so I can sell you a book and
I can say this is going to change your
life if you apply it if you don't if
your life doesn't change I just say well
you didn't apply it right like it's it's
there's this weird relationship it's not
clear the value it's not so easy to like
quantify education so that gets co-opted
by people who make all the promises
they get a ton of attention a ton of
money and then those people are often
left left confused and like kind of
disillusioned maybe thinking well this
didn't work in one year so it's not
going to work at all
um and so I think yeah there there are
problems there there's certainly a need
for like male role models there's
certainly a need for somebody kind of to
speak to a younger generation I just
think that person shouldn't
shouldn't be maybe Andrew Tate like
personally yeah so you have to criticize
those particular individuals uh I also
yeah I think that like the Bugatti
aspiration is so stupid like it's like
it's so well let me steal man so I'm a
person who doesn't care about money
don't like money
um the women maybe I appreciate the sort
of the the beauty of the other uh the
other sex but like sure
um yeah cars in particular is like
really is this really the manifestation
of all the highest accomplishments a
human being can have in life yes I can
criticize all that but the to Steel man
that case is um
a young person a dreamer has ambition
and I often find that education
throughout my whole life there's been
people who love me teachers who saw
ambition in me and tried to reason with
me that my ambition is not justified
looking at the data look kid you're not
that special yeah look at the data right
you're not and they they want to do they
want you to like not dream essentially
and then again I look at the data which
is
all the people I just talked to haja
Gracie this Hydra Gracie is just a
person widely acknowledges probably the
greatest of all time dominated everybody
but for the longest time he sucked
and he's so he was surrounded by people
that kind of you know don't don't
necessarily believe in him so he had to
believe in himself you have to it's nice
to have somebody I just as older I get
and I've seen it it's so powerful to
have somebody who comes to you an older
person
whether it's real or not that says you
guys in you I believe in you sure yeah
it yeah it does I mean
I think so
I think dreaming is actually really
important
I'm more protective over People Co-Op
those dreams for money yes yes and like
I do think it matters so much that we
encourage people to take risks it's one
of the great things about America is it
lionizes like sort of people have taken
risks and one
but
I think it's just a weird
vapid thing when like the reason you do
all of it is for this thing you can get
out at the end of the day when we all
know and you like you've just heard a
million interviews like nobody ever is
gets the Bugatti and goes this now
completely fulfills me everyone knows
the the Beauty and the like fulfillment
actually comes from becoming obsessed
about what you're doing for its own sake
sort of the journey the beauty of that
thing
um and I think money's just this thing
we have to deal with to be able to do
cool stuff like I acknowledge that you
know you need money to build the 10
million dollar Studio like you got to
get the cameras you got to get the
lights and I'm very blessed to be able
to have gotten that but past a certain
point like I think that is really the
function of money is to just do cool
stuff but ultimately if you can't
fall in love with the process and like
the craft itself you will be left very
unhappy at the end of it
and so to start people off on that
Journey
by pointing to the shiny object and
going like that's what you should care
about seems to me so backwards we should
learn from the actual people who have
done it and said that shiny thing did
nothing for me
learn to love the journey and like
that's the thing we pitch people as
unsexy as that might be yeah absolutely
that's what I said and the same applies
to like the red pill community that
talks about dating and so on that
there's uh there is
uh it's not just about the number of hot
women
you go to bed with it's also about
intimacy and love and all those kinds of
things and so like it there there's
components to a fulfilling life
that uh is important to sort of educate
young people about totally but at the
same time feeding the dream is saying
take big risks sure and you the little
you that has no evidence of ever being
great can be great because there's
evidence time and time again of people
that come from very humble beginnings
and doing incredible things that change
the world yeah and there's just a
tremendous like funny thing where you
can't become great without having a
willful denial of the statistics like in
some ways you have to take the chance
even if that chance is so improbable and
it's always those people who did take
that chance to end up pointing so I
agree
probably SBF and FTX is the biggest
thing you've ever covered but previously
you've called the save the kids scam the
world's influence the scam like the the
the the biggest in the world influences
cam you've ever seen uh can you describe
it
sure so save the kids was a charity coin
that was launched by
a number of extremely popular
influencers I think they had over 50
million followers together
huge names and they basically said hey
guys invest in this coin We're Gonna
Save the kids
portion of the proceeds go to charity
and this coin it's unruggable so rugging
is the term for remember earlier we
talked about safe Moon you just grab the
pool of funds in the middle and you take
them out okay it's unruggable because we
have this smart code that is going to
prevent
people who are quote whales which is a
crypto term for saying you have a large
portion of the tokens
it'll prevent those people from selling
a large amount of that at one time right
and so basically you don't have to worry
about trusting us it just is what it is
join and we will you know change the
world save the kids whatever
it was really skeezy from the beginning
and sketchy because their logo matched
the save the children logo which is like
an actual charity that you know so they
basically copied it and said we're
saving the kids
um like a knockoff brand and almost
immediately the project rugged the they
stole the money and tracing back through
the code was just changed at the last
second before launch like if you looked
at their code that they launched as a
test versus the code they launched in
actuality they changed only like two
lines and it was the whale code to
basically make the whale code
non-existent like you can sell as much
as you want as fast as you want
um and it turned out that some of the
influencers had not only
sold that and made money but also had a
pattern of pump and dumping tokens so we
can talk about what that is like yeah
what's pumping up a pump and dump is
just where you know you have a huge
following you promote your little Lex
coin to everybody while holding a big
portion of it and as everyone rushes in
to buy it the price is going to pump
and you dump at the same time so that's
where the name comes from pump and dump
you pump the price sell all your tokens
make a lot of money so I traced
basically their Wallets on the
blockchain and found that two of the
actors specifically had had a long
history of doing this
um which really proved malicious intent
and why I called it the worst is not it
certainly wasn't the worst in terms of
like the amount of people affected it uh
relatively was like a small pump and
dump because it rugged almost
immediately
but in terms of the amount of people
that were involved in it in terms of the
amount of malicious behavior before it
that like sort of proved that this
wasn't an accident the fact that there
was like this whale code it was one of
the most cynical attempts to just take
the money of the followers you had and
just like
that's mine now so that's that's why I
called it that let's save the kids so
that was uh that was a lot of the phase
members and uh it was I think Addison
Ray there were a lot of people who
seemed like they were kind of taking
shrapnel on it there was like this guy
Tico who he didn't even sell the tokens
he just like held on to it the entire
time and lost like a few thousand
dollars or maybe even I forget the exact
amount he lost a lot of money a decent
amount and so like he took a lot of
shrapnel with that but there were also
people who were maliciously doing this
so
in that investigation like several of
the members of phase got kicked out
one of them got like permanently banned
and then this other guy that I talked
about fled the country like he sold all
his belongings and like fled the country
and you know hid out in in London or
wherever he is now I don't really know
where he is somewhere in the UK area so
the basic idea there is to try to
convert your influence into money
correct
okay that's the basic idea behind a lot
of influencer crypto promotions
well but right but that that little word
influencer means something because there
are most crypto scams influences scams
they're not right most
most cut right most high profile ones
like just by Nature they tend to be made
high profile by the influencer so
sometimes they are but you're right a
lot of money has been lost and like
nobody finds out because there's no one
big sort of attached to it they just
steal a lot of money but
um influencers are great sales people
because like in order to overcome the
resistance of getting you to buy some
random coin there has to be a reason and
so much of the 21st century content
creator generation is defined by these
strange parasocial relationships where
people feel like they know you not the
character you play but you and you have
some friendship with them when in
actuality you don't know the viewers you
know you have a sense but you don't
actually know all of these people and so
that relationship is extremely powerful
in terms of persuasion so you can say I
believe in this and I've watched you
year for you years and all of a sudden I
say if Lex believes in I believe in it I
trust him as a human and so that
differentiates these coins and all of a
sudden the coin blows up gets really
popular yeah you made this side deal you
make a ton of money I have to say
podcasting in particular is an intimacy
like I'm a huge fan of podcasts and I
feel like I'm friends with the people I
listen to right and boys that are
responsibility yes
and that's that's why it it uh really
hurts me to announce that I am launching
Lex coin no
no man I uh this uh the the I hate money
I hate this kind of the scheminess of
all of this the the use the use of any
kind of degree of Fame that you have for
that kind of stuff there's something
just so like frustrating is these people
disgusting I have a general sense of
what they were like sort of what I'm I'm
in the even though I wouldn't describe
myself as an influencer I make content
on YouTube
I know that especially since they were
taking these huge corporate sponsorships
they were making tons of money they
didn't have need for these scams I mean
I think it's one thing to scam if you're
like broke on the street you know and
you're playing three card Monty to like
live and I think it's a whole other
ethically cruel thing to do if you're
basically trying to upgrade your
Penthouse to the building next door and
like you're already well off and you
just kind of want to get even further
ahead I think that's where it well this
is the fascinating thing yes I've been
very fortunate recently to sort of
um get uh you know whatever a larger
platform and when you find out is like
life is amazing I always thought life is
amazing but yeah it becomes more amazing
like you meet so many cool people and so
on but what you start getting is you
have more opportunities to like
yeah like P like scammers will come to
you and then try to use you right and um
I could see for somebody it could be
tempting to be like oh it would be nice
to make some money I wanted to say like
on this kind of we're on this topic of
opportunities you get you know kind of
when you get a platform
so one of the reasons kind of I railed a
little bit earlier against um
materialism or whatever I think to the
extent to which you can moderate your
own greed
you can play longer term games and I
think so many people end up cutting an
otherwise promising career short by just
wanting it too fast so I think it's like
a huge Edge just like discipline is in
terms of like achieving what you want I
think I'm like a very moderate like
being comfortable with a moderate
existence and finding happiness in that
is a huge Edge because really your
overhead is so much cheaper than the
people who need a Ferrari or a super
nice house to feel fulfilled and when
your overhead is less you have the
luxury to say no to like sketchy offers
that the different you have freedom that
other people don't have because
a lot of times people don't pitch it
this way they pitch a Ferrari as Freedom
or like a big houses like you've made it
in a lot of ways those shackle you back
to like you gotta find the cash flow for
those things it's never a free ride yeah
that's really beautifully put I I've
always said that I had [ __ ] you money at
the very beginning I was broke for most
of my life
the way you have [ __ ] you money is by
not needing much to say [ __ ] you that's
that's the threat I mean that's the
overhead that you're talking about if
you can live if you can live simply and
be truly happy and be truly free I think
that means
um that means you could be free at any
in any kind of situation you could make
the wise kind of decisions and in that
case money
uh enables you in certain ways to do
more cool stuff but it doesn't shackle
you like you said too many people in the
society would shackle because material
possession is kind of like draw you into
this race
um of uh more and more and more and more
and then you feel the burden of that
bigger houses and all that kind of stuff
and now now you have to keep working now
you have to keep doing this thing like
you have to make more money and if it's
a YouTube channel and so on you have to
you have to get more in the same it's
not even just about money
um that's why I
deliberately don't check views and likes
and all that kind of stuff is you don't
want that dopamine of like
um of pulling you in I have to do the
thing that gets more and more attention
or
um more and more like yeah like money
and yeah wise yeah it's a huge negative
hit on your um
and you're
ability to do creative work can can I
ask you about that because I always I'm
always interested in this
um I completely agree I think it's funny
because when you abstract yourself out
to the people you admire and respect who
inspired you to do the Creative work you
do
you never think about like the views
they were getting or the money they were
making or the influence they had all you
ever think about is the work itself
and it's funny when a lot of people get
in this position
your temptation is to focus on that
which you can measure which is like all
the stuff you said like the likes the
view that's not actually the Target or
what you got into it for if you get into
it for like because you're inspired or
whatever your goal is inspiration it's
impact and like that can't be Quantified
that same way
so it's interesting you have to find a
way as a creator of any of this stuff to
like deliberately detach yourself from
the measurable and focus on this thing
which is kind of abstract and I was
wondering if you have any like ideas for
that so one yeah there's a bunch of
ideas so one is
uh
figure out ways Where You Don't See
the number of views on things so I have
I wrote a Chrome extension for myself
that hides the number of views
um that's really funny yeah I know
what's funny is I have me because it's
useful for other people oh my God my
gosh I'm gonna need to borrow this that
was my problem I actually have some
Chrome extensions for like I don't like
going down like recommendation rabbit
holes when I'm at work I just want to
like search for a video find it I don't
want to see like all the up next because
I'll waste time so I use Chrome
extensions for that but the views is a
problem because it's relevant to me as a
Creator like is this a big video is it
us yeah which is why I really hurt when
they remove like likes and dislikes
because I want to know for tutorials and
so on uh what's I mean that's probably
really useful for you that dislikes yeah
yeah do you have that do you ever ever
considered making that Chrome extension
public sure it actually yeah and there
would be a good philosophy behind it
right like don't if you're a Creator
like I love the idea I've wanted this
thing before I don't know if it
necessarily exists because I don't think
I've made a a Chrome extension public
that'd be cool I would love to see yeah
I would go to that process of adding it
to the because I love like open sourcing
stuff so yeah I'll go add it to the
Chrome extension like the the store yeah
because I I totally have I've hated this
for like a long time YouTube made a
change and they just continue to make
the analytics front and center which
makes sense from their perspective
they're trying to give people better
data on what is successful and what
makes something successful they're
trying to train their creators but in
the process it can lead to some
unhealthy habits of thinking views to
find a video and so I've long thought
okay I've learned analytics I understand
retention now I sort of want to do like
the Zen like forget it all though and
you can only do that if it's out of your
site depends how many friends you have
who are creators the other really
important thing and I found this this
has nothing to do with creatives but uh
people are respect very much in my life
some of them people would know that they
could be famous
they will come to me and say they will
comment on how popular a video was on
YouTube
they will sort of complement
the success the the success defined by
the popularity even for a podcast where
most of the the listenership is not on
YouTube or in Spotify now is getting
crazy the they will still complement the
YouTube number so one of the deliberate
things I do is I either depending if
it's a close friend I'll get offended
and made fun of them for that and to
sort of signal to them this is not the
right thing yeah I don't want that and
uh for people more like strangers that
complement that kind of stuff I shown
zero interest I don't receive the
compliment well and I will focus on the
aspects of the compliment that have to
do with like what what do they find
interesting uh you know I kind of make
them reveal to them that you shouldn't
care about the number the number of
views it is strange there's like this
weird hypnotism that happens once you
get past a certain number
and that number is some approximation
it's like it's always like hard numbers
it's like 100 000 a million 10 million
people just see a number and they just
go like wow that is and they assign a
quality to it that may not like it
usually means nothing at all so I agree
I've never I've never been good at like
handling that because you're like thank
you yeah and I was like okay okay that
said I do admire very different for me
but I admire Mr Beast who
unapologetically
says like the number is all that matters
like basically the number shows like the
number of views you get
shows like how much
uh I don't know Joy you brought to
people's lives because if they watch the
thing they kept watching the thing they
didn't turn to now that means they loved
it you brought value to their life you
brought enjoyment and I'm going to bring
the the maximum amount of enjoyment to
the maximum number of people and I'm
gonna do the most epic videos and all
that kind of stuff so I admire that when
you're so unapologetically into the
numbers yeah he's sort of it's
interesting he's like
gosh we're getting way too in the
weights am I is this a I don't know I'm
like constantly self-monitoring about
like what topics going on but if we can
Mr Beast is so interesting because he's
almost done what have you ever seen
Moneyball
uh yes it's the story of how someone
brought statistics to baseball and it
revolutionized everything he's
moneyballed YouTube yeah he took
statistics to YouTube and it changed
everything and everybody now
so many people are playing catch-up I
think it would be interesting
in a few years to see how he develops
and now that he's like kind of
revolutionized like the data side of
things
how he then approaches future videos
because there's a point at which
you've optimized you've optimized you've
optimized but optimizing for short-term
video performance is not the same as
optimizing for long-term viewer
happiness yeah and how do you do that
assuming the YouTube algorithm does not
perfectly already do it for you which it
doesn't but they're trying to obviously
do that optimize for long-term happiness
but and also growing Optimizer for
long-term creative growth sure I think
the thing that people don't I mean maybe
I don't know I don't actually don't know
enough about Jimmy but like to me the
thing that seems to be special about him
isn't the Money Ball aspect that that's
really important it's like taking the
data seriously but to me is that the
part of the idea generation
the constant brainstorming coming up
with videos so it's nice to connect the
idea generation with the with the data
but like how many people when they
create on YouTube and other platforms
really generate a huge amount of ideas
like constantly brainstorm constantly
constantly brainstorm at least for me I
don't
I don't like I don't think I go uh so
many steps ahead in my thinking I don't
like try to come up with all possible
conversations that don't come up with
all possible videos I can make but but
you can't so the one mistake to make is
to and map Jimmy's philosophy onto every
genre because not every genre fits that
model your model is not an idea Centric
model it's a people-centric model and so
you like
if you were in the business of creating
just Mass entertainment for the sake of
mass entertainment you might focus on
Okay the reason going idea focused
instead of person focused is so such a
revolutionary idea in some senses is
because ideas can be broader more
broadly appealing than any single human
can be
but you're not going for that you're
going for a podcast interview and I
think for you
the goal should always be how deep can
you get with interesting guests and like
finding the most interesting guest which
is a different probably set of skills
than well really well put but I think
the the right mapping there is finding
the most interesting guest yeah and I I
think uh I don't do enough work on that
so for example I I I I try to be
something I do prioritize is is talking
to people that nobody's talked to before
so
because it's like I kind of my see
myself as not a good like I know a lot
of people are much better than me I
really admire I think uh Joe Rogan is
still the goat he's just an incredible
conversationalist so it's like all right
who is somebody Joe's not gonna talk to
uh
not either he's not interested it's not
it's not gonna happen like I want to
talk to that person I want to I want to
reveal the interesting aspect to that
person and I think
I should do a Mr B style rigger in
searching for interesting people and you
should probably find people to help you
search sure so he does that but if
you're being honest he does that of
course with other other folks but he is
the main engine yeah you need like sort
of like a a pre-filter you're the final
filter because your problem is
you're only able to think of humans that
you've thought of before or been exposed
to and most of the world you've never
been exposed to so you need people to
like pre-filter and go okay these guys
are just interesting humans Lex has
never heard of them and then you sort of
take a batch of like a hundred people
and you go who seems the most
interesting for me yeah but by the way
on that topic we're
I have uh almost done I'm building up uh
I I programmed uh this guest
recommendation thing where I want to get
suggestions from other people because I
really want to find people that nobody
knows this is the tricky thing like not
you're not famous but I I the the idea
is there's probably fascinating humans
out there that nobody knows correct that
I want to find those and I believe in
the crowdsourcing aspect we'll raise
them and now of course the top 100 will
be crypto scams no but yes so like I
have to make sure that these kinds of
swarms of human humans that recommend I
can filter through in this whole kinds
of systems for that but I want to find
the the fascinating people out there
that nobody's ever heard from and um
from a programmer perspective I thought
surely I could do that by just building
the system yeah that's how programmers
always think they'll just automate a
system to do it well that's the Jimmy
Moneyball right like looking at the data
uh
uh Weeds on Weeds how do we get to Mr
Beast exactly I'm not sure okay let's
see if the kids
yeah let me ask you more on the guru
front you've uh okay let's start with
somebody that you've covered that I
think you've covered a lot and I'm
really embarrassed to not know much
about them I think this is like old
school coffee so you've been through
stages okay I've been through stages and
phases uh so a character named Dan Lok
yeah uh
who is he you've uh you've exposed him
for cult like uh human and his cult-like
practices who is he what has he done so
Dan Lok is sort of he's gone through a
number of iterations but he was kind of
this like sales trainer guy who really
made a hard push into what he called
high ticket sales and he was telling
people that they could kind of escape
the the nine to five Rat Race if they
just learn High ticket sales and they
can have the life of their dreams
basically it's like I'll teach you to
sell but I'll teach you to ask like not
only will I teach you to sell sell you
that pin but I'll teach you to sell it
for fifty thousand dollars instead of a
dollar right
um so I talked to a lot of the people
who had taken this course because it was
pretty expensive I think it was like
2 500 or a thousand dollars and mind you
the people who are taking it are like
teachers and like people who don't have
a lot of money and then you take the
course and immediately you find out okay
well there's an upsell at the end of the
course you're not ready you need to go
from like high ticket closer which is
one of the products to Inner Circle or
like the level up right and all of these
courses are structured like this so they
spend a tremendous amount on Google ads
to get people in the door promising the
dream and then once you're in you're
actually not done being like the product
you're actually in this system that
tries to upsell you again and again and
again and again and eventually you're
paying monthly and you're getting more
and more you're constantly paying for
access to Dan locks wisdom and like
ideas and fundamentally
this sales system wasn't working for
people I mean I talked to like for
example a teacher who put in like twenty
five thousand dollars
was in debt at one point and has nothing
to show for it I know and it was sort of
these tactics of pressuring pressuring
pressuring and then anytime anyone would
complain he would try to silence them so
I heard from like
um funny enough this lady was a teacher
as well she put together a Facebook
group basically saying I think this
guy's a scam his course didn't work it's
not working for a lot of people
because fundamentally the promise of
turning someone from a non-salesman into
a
person who's making six figures selling
is not an easy thing to do it's not just
a matter of just like take my course but
anyways it wasn't working she created a
Facebook group about it and he liked
suser or and was like legally pressuring
her to stop doing that
um and I realized like somebody has to
speak out about this and everyone who is
is getting silenced so I was like I'm
going to use my platform to raise
awareness to this and people came out of
the woodwork I mean saying that this guy
defrauded me or he scammed me and I want
to just really quickly take a second
take a beat to explain why get rich
quick schemes are different
then let's say selling a water bottle
and saying it's the greatest water
bottle ever right because sometimes
people wonder they go like well doesn't
like
Nissan say their car is going to make
you happy and then it doesn't make you
happy like why is that different from
the kind of advertising of
a get rich quick course I mean both of
them are sort of promising things that
aren't true but you get something you
take some kind of a training you know
isn't it the same thing
no here's why
there's this concept in economics called
elastic demand and inelastic demand
what it essentially means is that if I
raise the value of this water bottle
there's a point at which you're just
going to be like no it doesn't make any
sense right
but there are areas in our lives where
we have desperation around them
that can get deeply predatory very
quickly because they have no
there's no elasticity around their
demand for example your health if you
get cancer and I have the pill
that will solve it or at least let's say
I don't I have a sugar pill here but if
I can convince you that this pill will
solve your cancer or treat your cancer
you will pay any amount of money you
have on this Earth
to get this pill that it but obviously
that gets really predatory really quick
because
selling something that isn't real is
almost as compelling as selling
something that is real right so this
happens in the get rich quick space too
there's any amount of money you would
pay to make a lot more money right
so these products have inelastic demand
that's why you see what is essentially a
few webinars getting sold for twenty
five hundred dollars
courses that literally have identical
videos on YouTube like very similar
curriculums that are selling for such
extravagant amounts of money and
I think there can be comparisons made to
college because obviously there's
similar like questions about benefits
but in this case there's not even
statistics available that even shows the
average person gets something out of it
that's true of like if you go to college
your average income will improve right
that's the justification there there's
none of that there's no case studies
there's nothing backing their
extravagant claims of you're going to
make all this money you're going to make
all this wealth instead they're just as
we said before they're selling you a
dream so that's why I find all those
like types of get rich quick schemes so
problematic and uh that's why I've
railed against them for a significant
amount of time what have you learned
from attacking exposing some of the
things that Den lock is is doing what
what have you learned about human nature
and and frosters and gurus and so on
that's a great question so
I think one of them is that
there's this systemic problem that
the the phrase there's a sucker born
every minute it's very true there is no
end to the people who will fall for
something like this and the problem is
is because there's just no end to need
and want and like and just lack I mean
it's easy to on the one hand criticize
people's greed but a lot of times you
have to put yourself in their shoes if
you're at a dead-end job
you have nothing going for you you don't
have the money to go to college you want
to get in debt fair play
where do you go right as you said
there's somebody who's there saying they
believe in you they believe you can make
six figures
you know you're you're gonna believe in
that and so
I really felt like
it made a lot more sense to tackle it
from the other side from the side of
people that can stop they can basically
be exposed and basically be
um have sort of like a negative put on
their work I mean they're largely going
under the radar so I kind of felt like
you know do you want to educate the do
you want to like blame it on the victims
and say you should have known better you
should have done this you should stop
but there there's no end no end to that
or do you go after the grifters
themselves and so that's what I realized
I realized like that's the tactic
that I went with
um and it's tough because it's a little
like legally risky to do that but
um
yeah you just kind of got to be smart
about it so your your platform has
gotten really big so there's some
responsibility to that weirdly big yeah
yeah
um
let's say because like only a year ago
it was like a lot a lot smaller and then
it's hard to make that adjustment you
know because like to me it's just the
same it's the same show I've been doing
so how do you avoid becoming a GUI
yourself or uh you you go growing in in
um there's different trajectories it
could take one one of which is you can
start seeing everybody as a scammer and
only you can reveal it and like ever and
like you have a audience of people who
love seeing the Epic Coffee Zilla
grilling sure and you can destroy
everyone and that power now is getting
to your head how do you avoid that well
I mean this is like less optically
obvious I think the main way is like my
circle of friends doesn't care about any
of that like and my wife doesn't care
the people that whose opinion I value
has no relation to like a subscriber
metric or anything like that I think
that's like tangibly the most important
thing to just staying grounded as far as
like becoming a guru I just don't have
anything to like sell I mean I'm not
interested in teaching people Finance
I'm not interested in teaching people
I'm not interested in selling a course
and I've kind of given myself a hard
line on that which I think has helped me
a bit is there's a temptation to go well
I can tell what's a scam so let me tell
you what's not a scam and a lot of
people have offered a lot of money to do
that and basically be like hey I have
such and such legitimate product come be
like an endorser and I just don't do
that because I think it undermines a lot
of what I do is if you get like
if you're taking money and on the side
to say this is legit and you're saying
this isn't legit that's a huge conflict
of interest so I think it's about
managing conflicts of interest and
keeping people around me that are
grounded and also I think um
yeah my only Interest really is just
like make cool stuff and I guess I'll do
that until people stop watching so
a question from on that topic from the
coffee Zilla subreddit shout out shout
out
how does coffee find the strength to
maintain his integrity and resist
temptation of being paid a great amount
of money to advertise or promote a
potential scam
uh I think that's like goes back to what
we've been talking about a lot which is
just on what you prioritize what you
value I've just never I guess I grew up
kind of lower middle class
and I had a great time like I had a
great childhood I had very loving
parents and because of that
I guess intuited at an early age that
money doesn't do a whole lot and I knew
a lot of people who were way better off
who had miserable childhoods because
whether their dad was always gone at
work or like they just had other family
issues that just money can't buy and I
realized
I guess quickly
um that money's a very like it's a
glittery object that isn't what it
appears to be and so to me I'm like I'm
having the time of my life making my
show
I'm not gonna have the like I could you
could ruin all that just trying to go
for this quick check when it's like no
I'm having a great time like yeah it's
actually uh maybe you're probably the
same way but uh for me there's a lot of
happiness and having integrity
in looking in the mirror and knowing
that you're the kind of person that has
that in fact walking away from money is
also fun
because it's it's like promising your
like it's showing it's easy to like just
say you have in Tech it's nice to like
huh I actually I've discovered several
times in my life that I haven't
decorated
you get put yeah you get put like
basically to the test yeah I I I've said
like I don't know if I publicly said but
to myself I say like you can't buy
there's a lot of things you can't buy
with me like four billion dollars like a
trillion dollars
um but it'd be nice to get tested that
way it'd be cool to see because you
never know until you're in that room
it's true
um the same with power given power I'd
like to believe I'm the kind of person
that wouldn't abuse power but you don't
know until you're tested so anyway I
you're in a really tricky position
because you're doing incredible I mean
you are a world-class journalist
straight up and so there is pressure on
that of like not having
like airing on the side of caution with
like having conflicts of interest and
stuff like that it's tough It's a really
tough seat to sit in
um it's really tough it's really tough
but it's unfairly tough I feel like
um but it's good that you're sort of um
weighing all of those but that said go
donate to coffeezilla donate all
everything support them it's a really
important really really important human
being
uh the other guy I did I think is the
first person I discovered that you
investigated as Brian Rose of London
reel
can you talk about his story
um
Brian Rose he was sort of this
interesting figure because he was like
trying to be to one level or another The
Joe Rogan of London which I don't think
he did a terribly bad job of especially
initially he had some really interesting
podcasts with some really interesting
people and uh it's funny enough I
started out as I like I would watch him
I mean I don't know if I was like a huge
fan but I was like I like some of his
interviews he had some really good like
big gits in terms of you know great
guests
um however when kind of covid started he
went down this really weird
grifting Rabbit Hole where he did like
this interview with David Ike who's as
you know like a pretty big coveted
conspiracy theorist
um and I mean like actual like he
believes some of the Royals are
literally lizards
um so he got shut down for that
and uh he kind of made a big stink which
it's I think it's fine nobody likes to
be censored and I'm not even saying that
he should have been censored but his
reaction to that was to like raise a ton
of money from his audience promising
this digital Freedom platform and at
first it was like oh we want to raise a
hundred thousand dollars and then they
raised it like within a day so he's like
well we gotta raise a lot more money and
So eventually they raised a million
dollars and he's trying to raise 250 000
a month to kind of keep putting
his viewers money into this stuff so I
started digging into the platform they
were building and there was nothing free
about it they had censorship guidelines
and there was nothing about a platform
at all there was no underlying
infrastructure he just got some White
Label uh live streaming thing so I
criticized him for that it was just this
ridiculous thing all the donators
expected one thing they they thought
Brian Rose was going to take on Google
and Facebook and like bring Free Speech
back for everybody and of course he
didn't
um and then it kind of got worse because
he started taking a lot of heat for that
and he really pivoted hard until like
the defy grift so he started selling
this course about defy Mastery and this
is a guy who knows nothing about crypto
um or very little at the least so it
just got really kind of he just kind of
um doubled down on this course model of
you're going to be rich if you just
follow me and it was
ultimately you just type in Brian rose
on on YouTube you can see what his
audience thought of that because almost
all of them have left him at this point
he's getting like a thousand views of
video
and it wasn't because of me I mean it
was like people lost taste in just the
constant ask for more money more money
more money at some point people get sick
of it and it's like everyone has an
understanding that like no one works for
free but when it starts to be ego driven
and driven around money everything's
about money it uh it drives people away
well you're a part of that sort of
helping people it's nice to have a voice
yeah I certainly spoke out I mean it
wasn't like I was quiet I was very loud
about it at the time
um but I mean in the sense that
there
if you look at someone like Andrew Tate
I made a video about him even though
he's been banned off all the platforms
he gets more views than Brian Rose
and
I think it's just like it was a
testament to how much Brian Rose was
like doing like the grift that people
could even people who were fans and
didn't care about what I said like
couldn't look past you know just the
constant ask for more and more money
people just get burned out
is there some aspect that you worry
about where with a large audience
there seems to be a certain aspect of
human nature where people like like to
see others destroyed sure uh do you
worry about hurting people that don't
deserve it or rather
sort of uh attacking people their
grifter light
but they get like a giant storm of
negativity towards them and therefore
sort of uh overpoweringly cancel them or
like yeah hurt them disproportionately
sure I mean I try to be sensitive to
my platform and as I've grown I've tried
to make sure my video topics have grown
with me and like
it does Reach This tricky point where if
you're exposing a grifter with like 50
000 Subs who's doing some harm are you
punching down right and
so far there's been enough high profile
things that I can distract myself with
to where this has never been a problem
you don't ever want to be
um
sort of like sir Lancelot in retirement
um where have you heard this analogy
okay so there's this great analogy where
it's like sir lancelot's the guy who uh
slays the dragon right he gets a lot of
Fame and he gets a lot of Fortune for
saving the dragon or at least a lot of
you know people love him
but what happens after he slays the
first dragon
he's got to go find a bigger dragon so
he goes finds a bigger dragon and
eventually depending on how many dragons
you think are there in the world maybe
he kills all the dragons
and one day people go see sir Lancelot
and he's in a field with cows and he's
chopping their heads yeah and he's he's
sort of put himself in retirement but he
can't even enjoy the fruits because his
whole thing is like I'm killing the
dragon so I try to be cognizant and I
try to always make myself willing to
hang up my my suspenders I guess hang up
my hat I I try to be aware like if I
significantly improve the problem I put
myself out of business
I want to be okay with that basically
um and just be fine with it I don't the
funny thing is I was more worried about
this as like an issue
earlier because I thought there was a
finite like I was like I'm gonna solve
this faster especially as it started
gaining traction like I'm gonna solve
this fast I got this you know classic
naive
um you know we all think we're so
influential TX comes along well yeah you
just you just yeah you just get like uh
with time you get humbled because you
talk to people I've talked to like
versions of coffeezilla that are older
and it's like it's like oh yeah they
didn't solve it and they probably were
better I just imagine a smoke-filled
room this is like of just like retired
Batman and you're at this young
bright-eyed
oh yeah yeah uh and you don't fiery
spirited investigator yeah exactly what
uh what's the process of investigation
that you can speak to what are some
interesting
um
things you've learned about what it
takes to do great investigations
sure great investigations reveal
something new or bring something to
light
so I think what everyone thinks in terms
of Investigations is like a lot of like
you know Googling or like searching
through articles I think uh that's the
first thing you want to get away from
and you want to try to talk to people
doing like the non-obvious things and
just trying to get perspectives that are
Beyond just what is available so a lot
of it's just having conversations is so
enlightening
um both to victims and also obviously
trying to get talked to the people
themselves secondly there's Sometimes
some analysis you can generate that's
meaningful like blockchain evidence so
in the case of safe moon for example uh
going back to that
I found someone's secret account where
they were pumping dumping coins they
were saying things like who sold I'll
I'll you know I'm so mad at the guy who
sold F the guy who sold and you look at
his account and he was the guy selling
and it's like that is just that's great
stuff so digging through the blockchain
kind of I've gained some skills there
um and that's kind of this fun I guess I
would say it's this weird Edge I have
for right now because a lot of people
don't know too much about that
um and so I have this weird expertise
that works now I don't think that'll
work forever because I think people will
kind of figure out how to do very
similar analyzes but uh so it's it's
like kind of an interesting Edge right
now that I have so that's like a data
driven investigation but you also do
interviews right yeah definitely and
then also recently I've tried to get
more response speaking to your point
about like as your platform gets bigger
you need more responsibility I've tried
to get much more
um
responsible about like reaching out or
somehow giving the subject some way to
talk because I think in early on I was
such a small channel that hey I if I ask
them they wouldn't answer but B I kind
of felt like I was launching these
videos into the abyss
and when some of my videos had real
traction I was like okay hang on a
second let's double check this let's
triple check it let's try to make sure
um all this stuff is correct and there's
no other side of the story
I'll say this has interesting
implications because for example I
investigated this thing called Genesis
they're a billion dollar crypto lender
and my conclusion was that they were
insolvent
that's a huge accusation so what do you
do well I emailed their press team
everybody I said hey I think you're
insolvent I think you're this I think I
laid out all my accusations and I said
you have till I think 2 p.m the next day
to respond
at 8 AM before I made my video they
announced all their investors that
they're freezing withdrawals they don't
have the money so they front I I don't
know if they saw the inner like I don't
know if they actually saw that email I
don't want to take credit for collapsing
them or whatever but my point is had I
not taken that level of kind of care and
just said hey you're a you're a scammer
your frauds ironically could I have done
more good by allowing people to withdraw
their money early
I made some tweets that people did see
that like some people got their money
out but my YouTube audience is much
larger and could I have helped more
people had I not given them basically
the ability to know what I was going to
produce when I produced it boy your life
is difficult because you can potentially
hurt the company that doesn't deserve it
if you're wrong or you if you're right
and you warn the company you might hurt
the
oh
uh well I'm glad your wife is a
supporter and keeps you strong that's a
tough tough decision
um ultimately I guess you want to err on
the side of the and of the individual
people
of uh the investors and so on but it's
tough It's always a really really tricky
decision to make very tricky
that's so interesting and then
um
the thing I've seen in your interviews I
that I don't remember because I I think
when you I watched you earlier in your
career you were a little bit harsher you
were having you were like trollier
you're having a little more fun sure and
when I've seen you recently you do have
the fun but whenever you interview you
seem respectful like like you you attack
in good faith which is really important
for an interviewer so then people can go
on and actually try to defend themselves
that's really important signal to send
to people because then you're not just
about tearing down you're after like the
you know it's cliche to say but the
truth like you're you're really trying
to actually investigate in good faith
which is great so that signal is out
there so like people like SBF could like
he should he should go on your platform
I think I mean now it's like in full
not just like a half-assed conversation
on Twitter space but in full yeah that's
that's great that that signal is out
there but of course the downside of sort
of as you as you become uh more famous
people might be scared to sort of go on
um but you're you do put that signal
being respectful out there which is
really really important you know it's
interesting
it surprises me I know it surprises
other people because other people have
commented but it consistently surprises
me how many people still talk to me
uh it's and maybe it's because they and
I really do give a good attempt to try
to argue in good faith I try not to just
like load up ad hominems or anything
like that I just try to present the
evidence and let the audience make up
their mind
um
but it surprises me sometimes that
people will just be like yeah they want
to talk they want to talk they want to
talk I think
it's very human in a way and I think
it's like almost
it's almost like good like one of the
things that is always told to everyone
who's going to talk to the cops is like
you should never talk to the cops
whatever
um which is true you shouldn't talk to
the cops because because even if you're
innocent they can use your words they
can twist your words Etc but there's
something that gets lost in that like
almost robotic like you know
self-interest that I think having open
conversations
even if you've done something wrong I
think there's something really
compelling about that that continues to
make people talk in interrogation rooms
in Twitter spaces wherever you are
regardless of whether you totally
shouldn't be talking and I don't want to
downplay that that's actually really
important I mean it's like a lot of
cases get solved a lot of Investigations
go farther because people sort of make
the miscalculation to talk but I think
it's like almost important in a way that
we have that human bias to like connect
in spite of self-interest yeah but also
they're judging the integrity and the
good faith of the other person so I
think when people consume your content
especially your latest content they know
that you're
a good person
I found myself
like there's a lot of journalists that
reach out to me
and I find myself like not wanting to
talk to them because I don't know if the
other person on the side is coming in
good faith even on silly stuff I'm not
uh same way like I'm not a I don't have
anything to hide like you don't really
have anything to hide but you're you
don't know
what their like spin is can can I tell
you an example I'm dying because I I
believe so strongly that journalists
have done themselves such a disservice
okay one of the truest things is that
like everyone loves journalism in theory
and almost everyone dislikes journalists
as a whole like there's a deep distrust
of journalists and there's a deep love
for journalism it's this weird
disconnect I think a lot of it can be
summarized in there's this book called
the the uh God what it's called I think
it's called the journalist and the
murderer it's written by Janet Malcolm
the first line of this book is that like
every journalist who knows what they're
doing who isn't too like is smart enough
to know what they're doing knows what
they're doing is deeply unethical or
something like that and what they're
talking about is that there's a
tradition in journalism to betray the
subject to lie to them in the hopes of
getting a story and play to their ego
and to their sense of self to make it
seem like you're going to write one
article and you stab them in the back at
the end when you press publish and you
write the totally different article this
is what actually everyone hates about
journalists and it's happened to me
before so I did a story like way back in
the day I got interviewed about
something that was like data with
YouTube
I made a few comments about data in
YouTube and somehow by the time the
article got published it's about me
endorsing their opinion that PewDiePie
is an anti-semite and I'm like I reach
out to this person I said I never said
that like what do you do how did you
even twist my words to say that and I
felt so disgusted and betrayed to have
like
I'm like this mouthpiece for an ideology
or like a thought that I do not actually
agree with
so and when journalists do this they
think well I'm never going to interview
this person again so it's okay so it's
like it's almost like the ends justify
the means I get the story but the ends
don't justify the means because you've
now undermined the entire Field's
credibility with that person and when
that happens enough time times you end
up sitting across from Lex Friedman and
it's like well I don't know if they're
gonna represent me fairly because the
base assumption is that regardless of
what the journalist says they could
betray you and they might betray you at
the end of the day and be saying you're
great while they're secretly writing
like a hit piece about like you know how
much you know you're a bad Force for the
world
where whereas there's an alternate
universe where if the journalist was
somewhat upfront about their approach
or at least didn't mislead and didn't
say like I love you I think you're great
um
you would end up with less access but
you would end up with more trusted
journalism which I think in the long run
would be better I think you get more
access I think in the long term yet but
all of these like everything we're
talking about is long-term games for
short-term games yeah in the short term
you get more access if you suck up to
the person if you say this say this say
this and you stab them in the back later
long term you build a long-term
reputation people trust you it actually
matters more but and it's nice when that
reputation is your own individuals like
you have a YouTube channel you're you're
one individual so people trust that
because you have a huge disincentive to
scoop people over true I feel like if
you're in the New York Times
if you screw somebody over the New York
Times gets the hit not you individually
so you can like uh
you're safer but like the reason I don't
screw people over is I know that I mean
well there's my own ethics and integrity
sure also there's a strong incentive to
like because you're now I'm going that
person is going to go public with me
screwing them over completely lying
about everything how I presented the
person for example and that's just gonna
you know that's gonna percolate
throughout the populace and they're
gonna be like Lex is the person is the
lying uh lying sack of [ __ ] and so
there's a huge disincentive to do that
yeah yeah challenge don't have that that
is what's interesting about yeah
independent the movement towards
independent journalism
um I think we'll probably end up at a
space where
it's so interesting mainstream
journalism has so much work to do to
repair the trust with the average
individual
um
and it's going to take a lot of like
self-reflection I've talked to a few
mainstream journalists about this and a
lot of them will admit it behind closed
doors but like there's this General
sense that oh the Public's not being
fair to us like they're very self
they're defensive I guess in a way and I
understand why because
sometimes it's just a few bad apples
that ruin it for everybody but without
the acknowledgment of the deep distrust
that they have with a good portion of
our society there's no way to rebuild
that just like when there's no
acknowledgment of the corruption of the
2008 financial crash there's no way to
rebuild that even if most Bankers most
Traders are not unethical or duplicitous
or they're totally normal people with
who maybe aren't deserving of the bad
reputation but you have to acknowledge
the damage that's been done by Bad
actors before you can like heal that
system well what do you think about Elon
just opening the door to a journalist to
see all the emails that were sent the
the quote-unquote Twitter files
yeah that's really interesting I mean I
saw a lot of I'm like in this weird
thing where I see I'm so I follow a lot
of independent people and I follow a lot
of mainstream journalists and that that
they're very polar opposite takes on
that uh people really quickly politicize
it but to me this thing that was
fascinating is just the transparency
that I've never see from one of the
really frustrating things to me because
a lot of this podcast has been about
interviewing tech people CEOs and so on
and they're just so guarded with
everything it's hard to get to and so
it's nice to get
um hopefully this is a signal look you
can be transparent like this is a signal
to increase transparency
hopefully so I don't yeah it's been
tribalized so quickly it's like I've
lost a lot of faith in that and
unfortunately it's been this like
bludgeon match of like
you know
if you're on the right you think it's
uncovering the greatest story ever about
Hunter Biden if you're on the left you
think they were just sharing they were
just silencing revenge porn pics of
Hunter Biden so therefore it was
justified and by the way Trump also sent
messages to Twitter so doesn't that mean
that like we should be criticizing it
just like this is goes back to why I
don't touch politics is because I think
as many problems as I have I think when
you become a polit like a journalist
that not even a political journalist
when you become a journalist in politics
you have like twice the problem so I'm
like I'm happy to be well outside of
that um kind of sphere but it's an
interesting
um it is interesting it twit you know
forget Twitter files but Twitter itself
is really really interesting for uh the
virality of information transfer yeah
and from a journalistic perspective it's
like how information travels how it
becomes distributed
that's interesting what do you think
about Twitter I'm always conflicted on
Twitter because I almost hate how much I
enjoy using it because I'm like this is
like this mindless Bird app is consuming
my time
um it's this incredible networking tool
but what's weird is when I think about
my own presence on Twitter they've
almost made it too easy to like say
something that you've half thought like
the friction to send a tweet is so much
less than like if I'm gonna make a
YouTube video there's several points at
which I'm like well what's the other
side what's this what's that there's no
friction there and so one thing I've
noticed is everyone I follow on Twitter
a lot of them after reading all their
tweets I think nothing more of them
nothing less of them but there's a lot
of them that I think less of and I don't
think I've ever had an experience where
I've read read someone tweets and I
think more of them no way and I'm like
what does that say that
yeah what is that like there's so many
people I
I admire
that the worst of them is represented on
Twitter yes like uh there's a there's a
lot of people there's a million examples
they become like snarky and uh sometimes
mocking and derisive and negative and
like emotional messes uh
I don't know yeah what is that
um maybe maybe we shouldn't criticize it
and accept that as like a beautiful raw
aspect of that human being but not
encompassing not representing the full
into but it does reflect like it's
impossible to not reflect it to some
extent or you'd have to counter that
bias really carefully because that is
them it is a thought they had it's just
probably something that should have been
an unexpressed thought perhaps
um so yeah I I kind of Wonder like my
I'm like should I be on Twitter but the
problem is is it's such a great place
where so many
like so much of the news happens on
Twitter so much of
the journalism breaks on Twitter even
people in the New York Times they'll
tweet their scoop you know like they'll
put that out on Twitter first so it's
this really weird thing where I'd love
to be off it and it's like too useful
for my job but I kind of I kind of hate
it no no you need to well it depends but
from my perspective you should be on it
oh absolutely definitely am yeah so like
a coffee Zilla should definitely be on
Twitter but
have uh developed the calluses and the
uh the strength to um not give in to the
sort of the Lesser aspects like that
because you're like us you're you're
silly you're funny you could be you
could be cutting with your humor I
wouldn't give in to the um
like the darker aspects of that like low
effort negativity if you're the way you
are in your videos I would say if you're
ever negative or making fun of stuff I
think that's high effort so I would
still put a lot of effort into it like
calmly thinking through that because and
also not giving into the dopamine desire
to do to say something that's going to
get a lot of likes uh you know I have
that all the time you you use Twitter
enough you realize certain messages that
are going to get more likes than others
and uh and they're usually the ones that
are Extreme More extreme yeah and like
emotional like
Lex is an idiot or like lexism the
greatest human being ever yeah it's much
better than oh wow what a polite nuanced
conversation I can tell you right now
which of those three tweets isn't going
to perform well
yeah yeah so I I think the extremes are
okay if you believe it okay I will
sometimes say
um positive things I said that the the
the the Twitter files released was
historic
of course this before I realized I mean
I I the reason I said it is not is
because the transparency it's so
refreshing to see some any love of
transparency
and then of course those kinds of
comments the way Twitter does is every
side will interpret it in the worst
possible way for them and they uh will
run with it or some say when it's
political yeah one side will interpret
yes
uh I agree with that historic they might
not have even read the article they just
like they literally or the Tweet thread
and they're just like it is historic
because it's always because Hunter Biden
was finally the the collusion or
whatever it is and then the other side
is like no it's it's a nothing Burger
um but yeah that that aspect of nuance
and then it's frozen in time even with
editing there's a so tough it's It's
Tricky but if you maintain a cool head
through all of that and
um hold to your ethics and your ideas
and use it to to spread the ideas which
you do extremely well on YouTube I think
I think it could be a really powerful
platform there's no other platform that
allows for the viral spread of ideas
good ideas then
um than this and this is where like
especially with Twitter spaces
I mean where else would I see I think
twice impromptu conversations with
coffee Zilla and SPF like never yeah
nowhere else because he wasn't going to
come on my show he wasn't going to come
on some big prepared thing it's like hey
YOLO let's go into Twitter space and I
like pop up and you know what's funny
and this I hope this release is late
enough or well SPF probably won't see
this yeah
um although I'm sure he's and
unfortunately unfortunately he will oh
okay yes well
hopefully I'll have time to enact my
little plan but
um I'm hoping if he goes on any future
spaces I can like haunt him from
interview to interview which is like I
keep showing up and he's like oh I hate
this guy but I think he's he's already
kind of probably
um
has like PTSD of like in the shadows
lurks of coffee Zilla that just would
that would just it's just like uh that
really amuses me I mean there's a
I think he honestly would enjoy talking
to you there's a aspect of Twitter
spaces that's a little uncertain of like
what are we doing here because there's
there's an urgency because other voices
might want to butt in exactly exactly if
it's an intimate one-on-one where you
can like breathe like hold on a second
yeah I think it's much easier so that
sense of course space is a little bit
negative
um that there there's too many voices if
if especially if it's a very
controversial kind of thing so yeah it's
tricky but at the same time the friction
it's so easy to just jump in yeah uh so
I I just
I mean I could I mean you just imagine
like a Twitter space with like zielinski
and Putin like
how else are these two going to talk
right like can't you imagine if you try
to set it up on Zoom like it never
happens it's never happened too many
delegates like just imagine the way it
happened like sitting there like he's
live it's live right just jumping in
it's hilarious
um
okay uh actually just done a small
attention so how how do you have a
productive day do you have any insights
on how to manage your time optimally
yeah I I mean I've gone the gamut of
from obsessive time tracking in 15
minute buckets to kind of like the The
Other Extreme where it's more
um
kind of like large-scale
some deep work here two-hour bucket you
know account for an hour of lunch and
some other thing but now now I just
roughly because I manage a team and
there's some things that kind of come up
I it's only a team of two it's not like
big but I just have things that are not
necessarily controllable by me I like
have to take some meetings or whatever
it's not as easy to plan out my day
ahead of time so I do a lot of
retrospective time management where I
look at my day and that's what I mostly
do now
um and I account did I spend this day
productively what could I do better and
then try to implement it in the future
so a lot of this I realized is very
personal for me
I do very well in Long streaks of
working and if I I can't do a lot of
work in 15 minutes I can't do a lot of
work in even an hour but if you give me
like three hours or five hours or six
hours of uninterrupted work that's like
that's where I get most of my stuff done
so from the it just it'd be fun to
explore those when you did 15 minute
buckets so you have a day in front of
you yeah and you have like a Google
sheet or a spreadsheet or something yeah
I did an Excel Excel uh and you're
do you have a plan for the day or do you
go like when you did it uh or you just
literally
sort of focus on a particular task and
then you're tracking as you're doing
that task of every 15 minutes yeah I
would kind of do it live
um I'm not so one of the reasons I'm so
obsessive about it is because I'm not
organized by nature and I lost like in
college I learned how much
lack of organization can just hurt you
in terms of output
and so I realized like I just had to
build systems that would enable me to
become more organized so uh
really I think I think that doing that
really taught me a lot about time in the
same way that tracking calories can
teach you about food yes like just
learning accounting for these things
will give you skills that eventually you
might not need to track on such a
granular level because you've kind of
like figured out so that's kind of how I
feel about it I think everyone should if
you care about productivity and stuff
should do a little bit of it I don't
think it's sustainable in the long term
it just takes so much effort and time to
like and I think the marginal
effect of it in the long term is kind of
minimal once you learn these basic
skills but um
yeah I was basically tracking like live
what I did and what I saw is that a lot
of my real work would be done in small
sections of the day and then it'd be
like a lot of just nothing like a lot of
small things where I'm busy but little
is being achieved and so I think that's
a really interesting Insight I've never
figured out how to unbusy myself and
focus on the like core Essentials I'm
still getting to that but
um it is interesting realizing most of
your day is like a lot of nothing and
then like some real deep work where most
of your value comes from is like 20 of
your day yeah I try to start every day
with that so the hardest task of the day
and you focus for long periods of time
and I also have the segment of two hours
or it's a set of tasks that I do every
single day the idea is you do that for
like your whole life it's like long-term
investment of Anki and it's just like
learning and
um
reminding yourself of facts you know
they're useful in your everyday life and
then for me also music I'll play a
little bit of music piano piano so like
keeping that regular thing is part of
your life and one thing that I've really
taken from this is because I've read all
the like I had a self-improvement phase
in my early 20s
um and one thing you learn is that
everyone wants to give you a broad
General solution
but really the real trick of figuring
out like optimizing is figuring out the
things that work for you specifically so
like one interesting thing you said is
like oh I like to do my hard work at the
beginning of the day
um
I know a lot of people recommend this
I've tried so many times and I just do
better work late at night and so usually
my streak of work is like from like
after dinner 7 30 to like 2 A.M that's
my prime time
um and so like a lot of my videos which
you'll see which is like lit from this
studio which appears to be daytime it's
like shot at 3am you know just like in a
caffeine field Rush
um but that's kind of how it works for
me and then also like with the social
outlets and stuff like that which it's
easy and I know I feel like we think
similarly on this so it's easy to
Discount these things as less relevant
because they don't have quantitative
metrics associated with them
but in terms of longevity and like I
think to be able to do creative work
there's an amount of recharge and like
re-inputting stuff that is frequently
discounted by People Like Us who are
like obsessed with you know quantitative
metrics and so I really found that some
of my best work gets done after I take
like a break or I like I'll I'll go play
like live sets uh of music and I mean
like that's like for me really
recharging but nowhere on a spreadsheet
is that going to show up as productive
or like meaningful but for me
for whatever reason it recharges me in a
way that like I need to pay attention to
yeah for sure I usually have a
spreadsheet a 15-minute increments when
I'm socially interacting with people and
I evaluate how I'm getting roasted right
now no I'm not it's actually I uh
probably roasting myself but I do find
that when I do have social interactions
I like to deal with people that are in
outside of that exceptionally busy
themselves because then you understand
the value of time
and when you understand the value of
time your interaction becomes more
intimate and intense
like the cliche of work hard Party hard
or whatever the cliches play hard damn
it whatever the uh
just kidding
um uh the
that I mean that cliche there's a truth
to that but the intensity of the social
interaction
even like you know it's not even the
intensity like it's not even the party
hard it's like um
even if you're going hiking and relaxing
and taking in nature so it's very
relaxed but you understand the value of
that there's when you put a huge amount
of value on those moments spent in
nature that recharges me much more so
you have to surround yourself with
people that think of life that way that
think about the value of every single
moment that's one of the things you do
when you break it up in 15-minute
increments is you realize how much time
there is in the day how much awesomeness
there's in the day to experience to get
done and so on and then so you can feel
that when you're with somebody
um and then for me personally like when
I interact with people I really like to
be fully present for the interaction
like I can tell this is for anyone who
has you know I've been the audience
forever so I I haven't been on the side
of the table before you're very intense
you look right in the eye you're like I
don't know about writing the eye contact
is an issue but yes Alexa is a Soulful
gaze guys just in case you're wondering
yeah it's very Soulful all right all
right
back to serious talk okay you've uh
you've studied a lot of people who lie
who defraud
uh cheat and scam
on a basic human level
um how do you have trouble trusting
human beings in your own life
uh how what's your relationship with
trust of other humans it's a great
question so funny enough before I did
this I was like an incorrigible Optimist
I
everything the sun shined every which
place
um I always saw like everybody is
fundamentally good nobody was bad it
just was like sort of that wrong place
wrong time bad incentives
that view has darkened significantly uh
but I just try to remember remember my
sample set and just like I'm just
sampling sort of the worst and uh I try
not to let it bleed into my
day-to-day life and I think I've I think
it's probably because I was such an
optimist early on that I've I've been
able to kind of retain some of it I call
it enlightened optimism like choosing to
be optimistic in the face of
a realistic sense of the problems in the
world and with a realistic sense of like
the scale and the challenge ahead
um I I actually think it's much braver
to be an optimist
when you're aware of what's going on in
the world than to be a cynic I think
being a complete cynic is maybe I'm not
saying it's wrong but I'm saying it's
maybe the easier way just mentally to
cope with so much negativity it's like
just saying well it's all bad it's all
doomed to fail it's all gonna go bust
is
easier
yeah that leap into a believing that's a
good world is um
it's a little it's a little baby Act of
Courage
at least I think so
I don't think it's naive
no it can be some people are naive that
are optimistic but but oftentimes
um just because someone's optimistic
does not mean they're naive they could
be full well aware of how troubling the
world is
and I also believe some of the people
you study
you know I'm a big believer that all of
us are capable of Good and Evil
um
so in some sense the people you study
are just uh the successful ones
the ones who uh
chose sort of the dark path and were
successful at it and I think all of us
can choose the dark path in life
um
it's uh that's like the
that's the responsibility we all carry
is we get to choose that at every moment
and it's like a big responsibility
and it's a chance to really have
integrity it is a chance to stand for
something good in this world and all of
us have that because I think all of us
are capable of you all of us could be
good Germans all of us could in
atrocities uh be part of the atrocities
yeah I think it's
I really have um especially in recent
years tried to
somewhat de-personalize my work and
um
see it almost like as like a I don't
know like a force of nature that I'm
fighting more than like individuals
because of this exact thing I think like
sort of therefore but the grace of God
their GOI is kind of a really profound
way to understand yourself
rather than is just like fundamentally
good and like and full of Integrity
acknowledging that so much of that is a
product of your environment and your
family and your upbringing
and so much of the people who don't have
that is a product of their environment
it doesn't absolve them but it gives you
more perspective
to tr like to sort of deal fairly if
that makes sense and not approach it
from a place of anger or a place of
outrage there is a sense of like sadness
for the victims there's a sense of
outrage for the victims but approach the
individual who's done the thing
from that
place of understanding of this isn't
just this person there's like a whole
broader thing going on here
uh do you have advice for young people
of how to live this life
how to have a career they can uh be
proud of so high school students college
students or maybe a life they can be
proud of
hmm it's a great well let me think about
this for a second
I think
don't be afraid to go against the grain
and sort of challenge
the expectations on you
um
like you sort of have to do this weird
thing where you acknowledge how
difficult it will be to achieve
something great while also Having the
courage to go for it anyways
and understanding that other people
don't have it figured out I think is a
big theme of my work which is that
everyone wants like the guru to show
them the way to show them the secrets so
much of life and achieving anything is
learning to figure it out yourself and
like The Meta skill of being an
autodidactic where you can I don't know
if I said that word right you basically
use self-teach you learn the meta skill
of like learning to learn I think that's
such an underrated aspect of Education
people leave education they go when am I
going to use two plus two we're not
going to learn you know use calculus but
so much of it is learning this higher
level abstract thinking that can apply
to anything and
getting that early on is um
incredibly powerful so yeah I would say
like a lot of it is
I guess to some extent like you kind of
have to do that Steve Jobs thing where
you realize that nobody else in the
world is smarter than you
and that both means that like they can't
show you the perfect way but it also
means you could do great things and kind
of chart your own path I don't know
that's so cheesy this is why I'm giving
advice it's like a cheese I mean and I
don't think it is I think my my journey
is so full of luck and like specific
experience I wonder how generalizable it
is but
if I've learned anything and if I could
talk specifically to myself I guess
that's what I would say I mean you
you've taken a very difficult path
and I think part of taking that path
like of a great journalist uh frankly is
like
I I can be I can be that person
like just believing in yourself that you
can take that because like if you see a
problem in the world
you could be the solution to that
problem
like you can solve that problem yeah I
think that's like uh it's really
important to believe that it's that it
depends maybe you're lucky to have the
belief inside yourself uh
maybe the thing that you're saying is
like don't look to others for that
strength
and also and also like be really
comfortable failing I think um
one of the best things that like you
would never know about me
just looking at my background that
helped me was playing music live
I had incredible amounts of stage fright
yeah growing up
mostly because I was terrible at piano I
was like sucked and I specific I taught
myself how to play and I joined jazz
band in like high school did it through
college I remember all my recitals I
messed up every single solo I ever did I
never like actually nailed it and every
time I'd go up there I'd like have so
much dread around this
and uh it was easier to get up there
because there were sort of some people
up there but eventually I started like
playing live too and I sucked at that
and I've just gone through the trenches
of like just like being publicly sort of
in my mind humiliated like per that
prepared me so much for what I do now of
trying to basically being Fearless of
failure
in the face of like a wide audience
I don't have that anymore because kind
of I've experienced so many iterations
of it at a smaller scale of just like
abject public humiliation to where it's
like not something that bothers me I
have no stage fright that doesn't bother
me anymore but
you'd think like oh maybe he just was
always good at this I was terrible at I
had a complete phobia about public
anything so
um
it was that rapid iteration of just
failure and eventually I just like came
to the conclusion of like I want to love
it I want to like love like getting up
on a stage and bombing if you can learn
to like love that and be Fearless there
there's almost nothing you can't do
yeah it's brilliant advice I I've I'm
I'm with you still terrifying to me like
live performance but yeah that's exactly
the feeling is loving
the fact that you tried and somehow
failure is like a deeper celebration of
the fact that you tried
because success is easy but like yes
failure is like yeah bombing I mean
music yeah I on small scale on the
smallest and the largest of stages I I'm
not going to say who but there's a huge
band
huge band that wanted to be gay on stage
and it probably will happen but like but
I turned it down because I was like
no because I'm gonna suck for sure so
the question is do you do I wanna suck
in the front of a very large live
audience yeah and uh and then I turn it
down I was like no no sure but now I
realize yes
embrace it it's gonna be good it's gonna
be good for you it's gonna crush your
ego to the degrees remaining yeah and
it's just good for you it's good not to
take yourself seriously and do those
kinds of things but honestly I feel that
way
in an audience
like in an open mic
it hurts that's why I really admire
Comedians and um
like uh I go to open mics all the time
with Comedians and musicians and I just
see them bomb and play play in front of
like just a few folks and they're
putting their heart out and especially
the ones that kind of suck but are going
all out anyway I think I think open mics
are the best place to learn though
because it's the lowest Stakes you can
get well while still being public if
you're gonna face like fears around this
because we're talking very specifically
like public speaking or any kind of like
you know being in front of a camera if
you're gonna face your fear you have to
do it and the easiest way to do it is to
lower the stakes you're not going to
start being Lex Friedman on stage with a
huge band you don't want to be like it's
like in that way it is so impossible
um but the more you lower the stakes and
just like open it up to like two
strangers five Strangers Like The the
most dive bar open mic you can go to and
like start performing that's that's
really what I did is like like I love
open mics now because it's like
low stakes on the one hand but you
really get the feeling of like going for
it and get better and better and better
at that yeah for sure
and then you'll get the strength to take
a bigger and bigger and bigger risks
listen coughing I'm a huge fan of yours
uh not just for who you are and but for
what you stand for people like you
are rare and they're a huge inspiration
I just I'm inspired by your fearlessness
that you're that you're taking on some
of the most powerful and richest people
in this world and doing so with respect
I think with with good faith but also
with the with the boldness and
fearlessness listen man I'm a huge fan
keep doing what you're doing as long as
you got the strength for it because I
think you inspire all of us you're doing
important work brother thanks for having
me
thanks for listening to this
conversation with coffee Zilla to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you some words from Walter
Lipman
there can be no higher law in journalism
than to tell the truth and to shame the
devil
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time